at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O well hey everybody yeah it's not
Wednesday it's Thursday and yet here we
are
yep Jen had to do the Disney thing yeah
I did Epcot yesterday yeah Epcot and
lots and lots of drinking well not not
that much drinking but some drinking not
going to lie we actually got worn out
before uh far before Epcot closed but we
got caught in a rainstorm so you know
we'll talk about that on the Sidetrack
show I guess more MH unless people are
interested but yeah cuz we're so we're
going to do the the Sidetrack show
tomorrow night so you get two nights in
a row all right it's a special
week but yeah so um I can't remember it
was maybe it was Zach was Zach uh the
one that um that recommended this topic
and I thought that we'd already done
this we kind of did we did a video a
long time ago that was about like
creepy YouTube videos like the history
behind them like I think we talked about
like I feel fantastic and sad Satan and
kind of like all the classics of the
genre but I realized that we hadn't done
one that was specifically just like
internet Mysteries and [__] like that so
I don't we got on the topic because we
were talking about 90s internet
that's yeah which was classic internet
it's back when the internet was the Wild
West you never it was a new
phenomenon you could have been watching
it on web TV or Prodigy remember that
[__] [__] that they had yeah yeah and
then uh you never could tell what it was
you were going to see they had some wild
ass websites like Gore gallery.com
and you weren't quite sure if what you
were seeing was true or not it was just
another time and a lot of these stories
come from that era some of them do yeah
it took me a while to kind of wiow out
like which ones I wanted to do because I
said I don't want to go Hog Wild and
like talk about [__] five things and
we'll be here all night but it's like
there were um I think I got it down to
three I was going to do four but it's CU
just kind of like I don't know the
fourth one I was like ah a lot of people
have covered that one I don't really do
it so I kind of wanted to cover ones
that were kind of famous but also I
don't know just ones that were
particularly interesting to me and these
are kind of the ones that most commonly
come up and these were the ones that I
thought were the most interesting so
that's the ones we're going to talk
about well do you want to tell them what
what they are um it's in the it's in the
description but we wanted to talk about
uh most mysterious song on on the
internet yeah because um cuz you know a
lot about that you saw that on uh on
Wang's show I've been following it for
years trying to figure out what that is
it's still well alert no one has figured
it out we got the recording so we can
play it for you hopefully it works
hopefully it works will we be able to
hear it when we play it too when they
hear it yes okay yeah right yes and uh
there shouldn't be any copyright strikes
because there's no copyright on it
nobody knows who the [__] it is I mean
shouldn't yeah it's just an old dark
wave song I think from probably the '90s
no ' 80s ' 80s okay yeah they know for
sure it was all well it was before 84
like between ' 82 and 84 so it must been
between 80 and 8 84 82 and 84 82 and 84
yeah yeah yeah they figure that out that
much but they don't know who it is no
yeah nobody knows and they don't know
where it's from but it's it's a good
song I Like it actually there doesn't
seem to be any other songs from this
band recorded they've
looked and they don't know what country
it's from it's just a a spooky song kind
of I remember it kind of I've heard it
in a long time I remember it kind of
sounding a little bit like kind of like
Joy Division and
uh I don't
know yeah so hard to say yeah I mean
nobody very early cure maybe enjy
division kind of kind of It kind of
struck me is more like a lot of the kind
of goth adjacent stuff that was going on
in the early 80s cuz I mean Joy Division
yeah a lot of bands ripped them off
later on but Joy Division sound was very
very singular nobody really like a lot
of people kind of tried to sound like
them but nobody sounded exactly like
that I don't think that you
could I don't think you could mistake
them for another band whoever it is
they're
dead or something or they don't want
anybody to know I don't know what the
deal it was 82 that far back there
probably
dead because it would have leaked
somebody said hey man they're playing
your old song they don't know who that
is it would have gotten back to them I
think they're dead I was watching I
think Simon Whistler did a video on this
I think it was that one that I was
watching and he was like you know how
this is going to be solved if it's ever
solved it's like there's going to be
like some like 60-year-old dad like
driving around and like he'll hear
something over the car radio or his kid
will play it or something like that he's
like hey that's my band it's like that's
how it's gonna be yeah there's probably
a few a few members still alive you
would think but they're probably in
their 60s or 70s and don't know what the
[__] you know don't even know what yeah
they'd have to be older than us by now
yeah like if they were and and the thing
about it too is that nobody knows I mean
I'm assuming it was a full band but
nobody knows it could have just been one
person yeah recording on different
tracks you know what I mean because it
definitely does seem to have you know
two guitars a bass a keyboard and drums
yeah but in the 80s you could have
recorded that all separ separately on
different yeah I mean well yeah and you
can still do that nowadays it may have
been just been one dude yeah so so
that's a possibility also and that dude
died or something because it really does
seem very strange and I think that's why
people are so fascinated by this
particular case yeah is because in this
day and age when like you hear a song
and like immediately you can figure out
who it is and it's like this one has
just um defied identification yeah since
uh 2007 was when I think it kind of
went uh public yeah so people have been
trying to figure out what the [__] this
song is since 2007 whatever it is it was
some kind of demo song well yeah a
single probably what they're thinking
because there doesn't seem to be any
other songs and they would have surfaced
people would said oh that sounds like
this other band yeah but there seems to
be just this
song I've heard some people say that
they thought it sounded like Dino layen
but but I was like I don't know I have a
couple of their CDs and it doesn't sound
like them to me and I didn't even think
they were around back then but maybe
they were cuz I mean I thought most of
their [__] I thought was like from the
90s and the 2000s but it doesn't sound
like it sounds more like somebody you
know like those well you know I don't
know how how much they know but um you
know like all those like kind of
gothrock yeah compilations that used to
get like back in the like from Cleopatra
and all that it sounds like a band that
would have been on one of those like one
of the old ones and then like never did
anything ever again it sounds like it
was recorded like on an on a on a six or
eight track recorder that's what it
sounded like to me it was something
small like it kind of remind it kind of
reminds me of somebody like dance
Society or something like that you know
like that song that that I have on my
phone that I play for you all the time
it's like that but more more crude we'll
get into it hold on let me go get some
ice got to go get ice I got to go get
ice I'm yeah um Zach says speaking of
age I gave myself an existential crisis
the other day when I realized I'll be 30
in 4 years and there are 16-year-olds
now born the year the original iPhone
came out yeah it's pretty weird to like
think about that and it's pretty weird
to think too because every now and then
like I don't usually think about it all
that hard but it's sometimes like we
have friends that are like young enough
to be our kids but you don't really like
think about it that way I don't know I
guess it's not weird I promise but yeah
it's just like every now and then I'm
like oh yeah I did this that and the
other thing cuz I was trying to think um
when I was at Epcot yesterday and I was
like man when was the last time I was at
Epcot and I was like God that must have
been like [__] 30 years ago I think
it was 30 years ago at least cuz we were
trying to figure out like some of the
rides that were there I was like who
well I don't remember this being here
like when I was here last time but the
first time I went to abcot was in the
year it opened in 1985 CU we went there
on a school field trip and I was in
fifth grade and I still remember that
some of the stuff is still there but
they've obviously added a lot of stuff
changed the glass man that last glass
for some reason every time I put my face
in there it smelled like that cat
food the P smell like I don't know why
it would smell like pate and I don't
think a cat got in there you never know
you never know what they get up to when
we're not around when we're sleeping and
stuff yeah they could be sticking their
faces and everywhere
[__] breathing and [__] it's just
like [__] cat
P yeah that's stuff that that's stuff
that Bambi yeah
eats um yeah Ben says I've never heard
of this mystery song and have no idea
you're GNA wait we got it it's good I
hope I like I said I I did it real quick
like before the show but hopefully it
works um before we get too much into it
though cuz we're going to do three cases
we're going to do mysterious song on the
internet we're going to talk about this
dude dude that uh allegedly sent emails
to his friends and family after he was
dead um which is kind of a weird case
and we're going to talk about the that
plague doctor video yeah you know what I
mean like the coded one talk yeah yeah
yeah I was going to do cicada 33012 but
I was like ah everybody's covered that
one and that one's kind of it's cool but
it's like they've you know I I don't
think it's anything all that
nefarious but so and I will say the
plague doctor one they think that maybe
has been solved I guess like in a
particular way if you believe them I
don't know but we'll kind of get into
that in a little bit yeah um October 8
said oh my goodness I'll be 60 October
6th yeah I mean we're getting there I
just turned 51 on Tuesday so I went back
in the archives and was watching the
shows from [__] four years ago and
seeing how much we changed I changed a
lot I was
skinny and then I got skinny fat and
then I [__] bulked up
and uh Jenny looked and sounded like a
child back then it Wasing
fun but U man we're both in training
Jenny's [__] she's making a huge com
back her body's getting [__] fine her
legs are like [__] strong as [__] man
you guys are going to
see yeah we're strengthening ourselves
for our 60s you know so when we get old
[__] we'll be in good shape it's like
a Bull workk against old buw workk
fighting against [__]
age uh hey Tammy show yeah I didn't know
you were going to be here Tammy cuz I
knew Eddie isard was tonight he said
just sitting waiting on Eddie okay well
yeah don't don't like watch the show
while you're watch you watch that [__]
and then you got to tell me about it
later on I'm about he said he's going to
be six I'm only five years away from
that basically maybe O is a she maybe
six years yeah well yeah you're
54 I think I'm 54 yeah uh yeah 5 July
1st 1969 I think I'm 54 yeah you turned
54 this year yeah um Ben says how do you
feel young still though well yeah I like
a lot of older people say that too like
it's like yeah I still feel like I'm
like [__] 30 yeah yeah it just it
just seems like [__] 35 was just
yesterday it goes fast the weird thing
about it is I always kind of felt like
it seems like when I think about it I'm
like holy [__] like some [__] happened
that I thought sound felt like yesterday
and it was like 30 years ago like I said
but then sometimes I don't know it's
it's like fast and slow at the same time
or it's like seems like a long time ago
but it doesn't seem like a long time ago
yeah it's it's a very weird situ I felt
like I felt like [__] though a couple
years back when my [__] hormones
crashed before I went on gear though
remember how [__] I was getting yeah
scared of everything I felt like I was
dying it's [__] weird you guys when
you guys get older your late 40s early
50s [__] you hit that Adrena pause
you won't know what it is it's just all
of a sudden your instant loss of [__]
confidence and life force and you feel
like you're dying that's what it is it's
that go on test we got some listeners
here took my advice it [__] helps out
a lot feel a lot
better Zach said I hope youall do the
Final Fantasy house cult someday CU
Tom's reaction to it will be hilarious
yeah I have it I have it on the list and
like I put it in the poll a couple of
times but it never wins but yeah I kind
of want to do it too what is it the
Final Fantasy house I don't know that
yeah he's he you like Zach is like
really good at like recommending stuff
cuz yeah he knows I'll react to it a
certain way yeah Zach's got that empathy
he's got that bath house empathy Bath
House empathy yeah he knows what a that
sounds like a novel that I would want to
read yeah you could write it you could
write it we then we could shoot it it'd
be an erotic movie like back in the 70s
oh my God that would be funny Zach would
be Zach was kind of have a starring role
in it okay yeah like
do this
yeah all right uh teip says oh yeah teip
says uh so glad you're on tonight while
I'm packing for my move had to rely on
your back catalog to get through
Wednesday night yeah sorry about that
yeah like I said I didn't get home last
night until like 11:30 I can't believe
man I'm going through the old catalog
man [__] remember the [__] we were
talking about a long time ago it sounds
it was like it was [__] yesterday I
can't believe this Show's kind of become
a cult [__]
classic yeah you we got people listen to
our back C
we're like the we're like The Velvet
Underground of YouTube
yeah like hard we we only have 14,000
subscribers which is a lot I mean but
you know um but it's not like hundreds
of thousands like some of the other
channels that I watch so it's just kind
of like but you know all the cool people
like hang out here and so we're just
like you know what I
mean you know
yep uh yeah let's see um man every time
I look down I'm getting further and
further off off the [__] screen well
what are you doing I don't know you
moving all right I'm not you're not
moving dude I'm not moving it must be
you you're just kind of I don't know
what the [__] you're doing back
there yeah he says only I'd be crazy
enough to move to emn is is that
Minnesota or Montana is that Minnesota I
can't remember all those M States we
need to like Ms that's Mississippi no I
said MN oh MN I said is that is that
Montana that's Minnesota I think yeah
cuz Montana I think is m o yeah
no that's no that's Missouri Mt [__]
probably something like mt now I can't
remember that's why you drinking my
drink oh sorry you got all kind of
problems what are you doing I just saw a
drink and grabbed it well you got the
big jar M I can't drink with the big jar
cuz then I have to like sit there with
both hands like that your hands are too
small cuz my hands are too little I'm
sitting there going like I'm drinking
out of [__] I'm drinking vodka of a
[__] cereal
bowl Z says I thought that was multiple
sclerosis MS
uh yeah Ben says don't move to Minnesota
I mean yeah yeah it is Minnesota okay so
I was right the first time I was right
the first time uh tequil says also uh
congrats on your marriage it was my
birthday too yeah thank you very much it
was my birthday too yeah yeah my
birthday was uh Tuesday you know we've
been married for [__] ever man it's
just we just had to make the [__] we
just had to do the paperwork that's all
yeah I mean we probably should I called
her my wife off and on for [__]
years if some dude tried to go sideways
where I go get away from my [__] wife
she became my wife when other
[__] were chasing after so I
had to K make the [__] serious yeah I
was whipping people's asses over well
you know you know it happens it happens
but yeah so we just we probably should
have done it a long time ago we maybe we
would have got some [__] bonus [__]
probably right but you know better late
than never I guess see what the VA sends
me yeah maybe maybe it'll be like really
cool I think we'll get a raise probably
a couple hundred dollar extra well I
mean that's better than nothing right I
mean and then I'll start we'll start
doing the paperwork for [__] get you
some uh health insurance for something
that'd be nice we'll see have some
health insurance for a
change I think I can also get um money
for school like if I wanted to go back
to school which I don't necessarily but
if I did it would be nice to have that
option you know what I mean got that 80%
VA yeah medical retirement Ben says it's
good that you're no longer living in sin
Jesus is happy now yeah yeah yeah no
we're still living in
sin we still do some unacceptable [__] I
mean we're in the sex
industry just with each other though so
far yeah yeah yep so but that's okay
that's okay yeah it's all fun of games
we we like it like that yeah we like it
like that we got people trying to
[__] get recruited
yeah I got a feeling aiyah is [__]
looking for a job maybe so we'll see
well like I said I can't afford to pay
nobody yet so yeah we'll
see and I wouldn't make no I pay just to
see that
yet why would make nobody do nothing for
free you know what I mean right so I
can't like really afford to pay them but
Aaliyah says she might jump in for the
live show if you're here Aaliyah go
ahead and drop something in the damn
she's like hey don't get my name out
your mouth she's saying yeah get my name
out your mouth she
fake Aaliyah's our one of our
daughters daughters little goth
daughters well I like I was saying
before it's just like when you hang out
with people and then you find out that
they're like half year AG or less than
half year
like I said it's not weird it's like you
don't really think
it yeah there just people I don't really
think about people um John Robertson
said finally made a live show again
congratulations on the marriage guys
that's awesome thank you Super Chat man
thank you Jeffy art for the Super Chat
happy birthday Jenny toasting with $5 $5
wine and $10 french fries yeah I was
always tell I was always telling Jen we
had to do surprise shows on [__] off
days because we have people that will
never be able to make our show yeah that
was another thing we were thinking about
doing that sometimes we might not even
announce it we might just like jump on
and do like a s show like but like at a
weird hour so we might end up doing that
at some point if we have time cuz I was
like that actually is a good idea
because I know that a lot of people are
always like oh they you know they live
in a different time zone or they work
certain hours or something like that and
they can't always catch a live one and I
was like so maybe we should just kind of
like Jump Around whenever we have time
and just come just jump in and do a S
track while we're [__] half
snooger like 4:00 in the morning hey
drunk as [__] yeah 4:00 in the morning
on a [__]
Tuesday just to see who watch that's how
we
roll oh my God it's uh yeah that
actually probably would be really fun
but but we we'll see we'll see I'm not
promising anything but I do think it's a
good idea I wanted to say too um again
thank you very much Jeffy art for the
super chat um that we had a new old
Patron over on our patreon uh so thank
you once again master of dungeons I
think you were uh on patreon before and
then gone but then returned so thank you
very much for that also got a little
super thanks um from yeah from a user
named rp7
r54 I think is I was just like okay
thank you so I had to write that down
yeah so yeah we have that set up like if
you ever if if you're not like here for
this for the um live stream like
obviously you can push a little super
thanks yeah super thanks is rare we we
rarely get one so if you give us a super
thanks we will definitely give you a
shout out we really appreciate them um
the show basically demonetized anything
we make off of it is cross between
Patron and the few super chats we get
now we understand that [__] times are
tough right now you know [__] the
economy is not going that good so we're
going to continue to do the show whether
it all y all pay us or not cuz we like
doing the show it is but [__] paying
paying us for it giving us a tip here
and there really [__] helps us
out
um but you know that's all that's all
I'm going to say about it it helps us
out thank
you Zach says when you guys used to
upload in the mornings I'd watch you
while eating breakfast yeah see so we'll
just kind of because yeah for a long
time we uploaded the shows and I usually
put them up at certain times live is so
much more fun though it is a lot more
fun and it's a lot easier for me because
I don't really have to like edit them
and that's kind of a big get instant
feedback from the fans is uh in in you
know on in the live streams is helps us
a lot and actually makes the shows a lot
better yeah I think they're a lot funner
because yeah we go off on a lot of
[__] tangents and some people piss
and moan it's just kind of like get back
to the topic and blah not so much
anymore because I think all these people
have [__] off now but um you know what
I mean anybody that like would have
watched it was just kind of like yeah
you're not going to change us or control
us we're [__] fix we're we're way we
do what we
want just like the cats we do what we
want entertainment show we're not here
to educate you okay people but the
information this they got Wikipedia man
[__] well that's what I mean it's
like you can get the information from
other places if that's all you want
we're just kind of here to use that as a
jumping off point for us to like talk
about that and talk about other [__] we
got people doing their commute that want
to hear us got people trying to go to
sleep that [__] listen to us to go
asleep [__] you got long haul
truckers [__] hauling [__] loads
listening to us while they're drive it
you know what I mean [__] so it this is
a this is a
show to kill time basically and to
socialize and to [__] show you guys
some [__] trippy [__] serial killers
weird [__] like the mysteries of the
internet we're going to talk about that
or just [__] talking before we go out
and begin the weekend or maybe we're
going to stay home for the weekend just
you know it's just it's a general show
we haven't decided yet yeah cuz I didn't
honestly I was I was doing Disney and
Epcot for two days um and I spent some
money but not much because my siblings
rule uh and they covered a lot of my
[__] well because my one of my brothers
works for Disney so he can get a bunch
of people in for free so he got me in
Epcot for free and my sister got me in
Disney for free now let me say Let me
let me help him out a little bit over
the years if you got any Disney agents
listening to us over the years I [__]
spilled a lot of information
about [__] that Disney employees told me
about Disney it wasn't her brother he
she hasn't he hasn't been working there
that long no he's been there a while
yeah but he I was talking about the [__]
that was going on [__] 10 years ago
15 years that was that was actually
people that don't work there anymore
they were they were some I dated some
the one group was face and then knew a
bunch of people that were fur if you use
Disney people know what I'm talking
about and then some mechanics that
worked there they were in they're in the
goth scene working for Disney and you
just I just heard about how that place
was [__] run and just didn't like it
rub me the wrong way well now I we were
talking about this at dinner yesterday
and my brother actually really really
likes it there and he's like and you get
a lot of he's like well the rules are
kind of strict but not that bad and he's
like um and you get a lot of perks I
mean he just got a raise he not only
gets in all the parks here for free he's
like I also get in Tokyo Disney for free
I get in Fr the Disney in France for
free uh the other one that wherever the
[__] it is um you know so he gets in all
the parks like around the world for fre
what I didn't like about what I don't
like about Disney is that they could
take a Disney
princess and use that actress in a like
a real Disney princess not a [__]
cartoon Disney prin you could take a
girl that works at Disney as as the
princess they could take her and use her
in
commercials and not even pay her a bone
bonus she see but you have to sign off
contract that says that then yeah I
would have never do that if I was if I
was Disney I would never make somebody
sign that I would say like if we use
your image in a [__] a lot of
companies do that though I hate to tell
you they're [__] they they will tell
you it's like if you are some kind of
public facing blahy blah you have to
sign a release that says we have a right
to your image and yada y [__] stupid
[__] it is stupid but a lot of companies
do that if I was an actor working for
Disney and they selected me to be in one
of their commercials I would at least
want a little bonus yeah you'd think you
know I don't know like I said I don't
know how they run it now cuz you know
you knew some people like a long time
ago that worked there but and I don't
know because my brother doesn't do he's
not like a character if they're going to
make a [__] commercial and use your
image and [__] you danc and dressed
up as [__] Prince Charming or some
[__] like that and it's and it's going
to be a commercial why can't you throw
that person in an extra grand for that
day of work it doesn't make any [__]
sense any other decent company would do
that
I just you know I just I just think
they're [__]
shyers they chisel every bit of [__]
money and work out of their employees
DVD Dragon says Tom I have an idea for a
podcast just you speculating on what
stack actors or Internet celebs are on
or what they should go on I would love
to do that well you would probably do
that you should probably do that he must
have asked about wasn't he the guy he
was asked about Bane it's the same same
guy who was it asked I don't know DVD
dragon dragon asked that okay yeah but I
don't remember who asked about that you
can probably check I said that I said
that Tom Hardy was probably on test and
and de ball go ahead and check the
internet and see if that's what it was
CU I'm sure that's leaked I think it was
probably injectable D de ball looking at
him he looked a little
puffy which is okay stack I probably
would have done nerone but
okay but yeah so um should we get to the
actual topic before it gets too late now
before we start talking about the song
should we play the
song Tom huh yeah let's talk pay
attention I didn't know what the what
the topic was we're start talking about
the song already yeah yeah yeah that's
the first thing that we're going to be
talking about like I said we're talking
about three cases and the Mysterious
song is the first one okay the most
mysterious song on the Internet is what
they call it that's what it's under on
Wikipedia um although I think although
it's also known as
like the wind because that's kind of
what the lyrics sound like blind the
wind which could also kind of be what
the lyrics are I've also seen it called
check it in check it out because that
was something that I think that was in
the um the what do you call the the [__]
on the file like the uh metadata yeah
yeah metadata that was the word I was
trying to think of or take it in take it
out so some people have called it that
as well but usually if you do M most
mysterious song on the internet this is
the song that will come up because it's
quite here's the weird thing about this
song we're going to give you a recording
of this song this came off with
somebody's tape tape cassette yeah we'll
get into they taped a German I think it
was a German radio program was it yeah
yeah that had like dark wve bands yeah
or just like ' 80s music 80s dark wave
type music the guy recorded this the
radio show it was a weekly show and that
became his favorite song but he never
could figure out who it was and he
traded it throughout the internet and
other people like it too but they never
could figure out who this was they still
don't they still don't know which is so
weird yeah so we're going to try to play
the song for you now let me see and
we'll see if it works if it works I mean
we should still be here okay but here it
is
hopefully uh or not
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe not
time to
Wi you
[Music]
can't mine
is Yes actually okay so y
[Music]
can
I mean you see what I'm
saying no no clearly not they sound
completely different now that I hear
it's almost kind like the
damn
slightly but it's yeah
obviously
super I would know that voice any and
this is before the dam started sounding
like that now well it Dam started
sounding like this more like an
87 well no no fantas came out in
[Music]
85 yeah Z said it almost sounds like d
Bowie there were a lot of bands in the
80s that signed
like especially like in in the goth
yeah I would call this a goth band a
dark Rave band yeah yeah for
sure and it's like it's
tantalizingly familiar I think that's
why it bothers so many people especially
People Like
Us Stu just like it sounds like it's
like I just can't quite place it
it's a good song it is I like
it it's in English but I'm pretty sure
theand yeah they're pretty
sure not not British think
European Russian but not not in that era
it's something kind of like German or
AUST stre maybe chat yeah that's cuz at
the ation
although for all we know this might have
been a cross the Iron
Curtain yeah it's possible cuz they were
making they they were listening to music
yeah you know they were they they were
digging I mean they were they were huge
Rolling Stone fans they were they were
digging all kinds of Western stuff that
could be Russian which that oh yeah it's
it's totally possible because like I
said we'll get into yeah where because a
lot of people have gotten really
invested in this cuz you know everybody
on the internet we all love a mystery
right and if you have some time on your
hands and you're really into that kind
of [__] like people have been looking
into this for since like I said about
2007 I think it picked up more you know
in later years but that was kind of when
people first started looking for it I
like the song I do too I'd like to I
like you to put that on the car
playlist yeah I think somebody uploaded
it to Spotify Spotify but they but they
claimed that they but they claimed uh
that they had written it or done and
everybody's like no it's like you w born
then when this [__] song came out
piss off but it's like at least somebody
put it on Spotify it's I think it's
under like the wind I'm not sure or
blind the wind I've seen it called that
too but I'm sure I could probably find
it good but yeah so here's how here's
how this happened so there's a guy named
Darius now I this is a pseudonym I'm
assuming because he doesn't really want
to um you know anybody know who he is or
whatever so sometime between 1982 and
1984 uh Darius he was a teenager then
and he was from
Germany and like a lot of kids in the
80s did cuz you know we didn't have
Spotify or nothing like that so you
would listen to radio shows that had
music on them and you would have your
cassette tapes and you would tape the
songs that you liked and like make mixes
with them so that's what he used to do
now one of the shows that he used to
like to listen to was called music for
young people except in German and I'm
probably not even going to attempt to
pronounce that music for a
young yeah it was probably like one
single word now the Germans are
music it's right here it's music for y l
music young people yeah yeah okay um
which was on the a public radio station
in Germany called
ndr1 now one of these tapes um which he
had labeled as cassette 4 had a bunch of
songs and most of these songs came out
in 1984 or prior to 1984 that's why most
people think this song was from 1984
because there were some songs by The
Cure on there there was like an XTC song
um but he had like all these songs on
there and if you look like on the
internet if you look up MOS misseri song
on the internet there's also this little
typed list that I'm presuming that he
made of like other songs that were on
that tape with this particular song and
those songs were one of them was Master
and servant by mode that was ' 84 or 83
or ' 84 that song came out um sunglasses
at night that Cory Hart song um Twilight
Zone by Golden Earring goldenring yeah
although I thought that was
82 but um another one of the songs on
there was the Ghostbusters theme by Ray
Parker Jr and that was definitely 84
because I remember that movie came out
in ' 84 cuz I saw it in the theater um
it also had songs by Heaven 17 on it
Malcolm McLaren Simple Minds Captain
sensible like some other stuff like that
but this song he called it I'm pretty
sure he typed it on there I think he
said blind the wind and then he just had
little question marks by it because one
thing that he would do and I think a lot
of us did this too it's like when he
would record the song He specifically
like didn't put any DJ information on
there because he didn't want it messing
up the song right you know what I mean
so it's like he would wait until they
sto yapping and then would start
recording the song and then like turn it
off where they start the DJ probably
said what it was well they don't yeah
they don't know he doesn't he didn't
remember like if the DJ said but he's
like I was in the habit of not recording
in them talking and I would just try to
like write it down yeah what's funny is
but he didn't catch like
whoever whoever did this song funny is
that they got the Ghostbusters theme
song played alongside this they got
[__] sunglasses at night which was
mainstream as [__] it was like a very
mainstream song but when you listen to
the song you're like well [__] something
off the first sisss of mercy first and
last and always album should kind of
sounds like that yeah would have been
gone along along with this you know what
I mean [__] but but they didn't play
it yeah
maybe it was wasn't known well first and
last and always didn't come out till 85
oh was 85 okay all right Sister of Mercy
and had they had put out some EPS prior
to that Alice was out by then yeah Alice
had come out before that like the Alice
um EP or that single and they had done
like some covers and they did like the
Body Electric and all that kind of like
the real old school sound [__] but yeah
first and last and always yeah didn't
come out yeah reptile house first and
last always saying Kam out 85 but yeah
so I I thought I too thought that was
very funny because um you know yeah you
had like depes mode yeah and then which
was pretty mainstream and then cat's
insensible but then like alongside like
Cory Hart and goldenring the
Ghostbusters theme super so it just like
an 80s and then to play this one song
that was like super obscure it's so
obscure that like nobody knows what what
the [__] it is even nowadays hilarious
why didd he throw in this obscure
[__] thing here unless maybe he knew
these dudes well a local band well no
cuz we'll get into that okay we'll get
we'll get into that so Darius the guy
that taped this supposedly he said now I
wasn't sure if I recorded the song
because he's like what I would do is
like I would record songs and like
sometimes I would mix them together like
from different broadcasts like on the
same tape so he's like so I can't be
100% sure that this particular song was
played with these other songs it was
just on the same tape you know what I
mean because he would mix them up
sometimes um but so so that's the thing
um and and as I said because a lot of
the other songs that he that were on the
same cassettes around from that period
were from 1984 like Ghostbusters they're
assuming that the song came out in ' 84
or a year or two prior to that also he
said that at the time he had like one of
those um
techniques uh tape recorders and those
were manufactured in 1984 so they're
pretty sure that that's when the song
was from or slightly before that now he
had the tapes for like 20 years he like
kind of just hung on to them in 2007
though he has a sister uh whose name is
Lydia like or that's her pseudonim I
don't know if that's her real name or
not and she got kind of fascinated about
this song cuz she liked it and she was
like I'm going to find out who that
[__] song is because all these years
like we didn't know who it was and they
would like play it sometimes and it was
like bugging them right so you know once
the internet became a thing CU this is
2007 by this point she starts searching
the lyrics like on the internet and
everything like that and couldn't find
anything so she finally decides well I'm
going to post this on some Forum
somewhere and see if somebody can help
me out maybe somebody will recognize it
or something like that so she goes under
a couple of pseudonyms online one of
them was Anton R ryell I think um or
blue with like a bunch of views in it
she actually took like not the whole
song but it's like a minute of the song
or something like that and she uploaded
it to um a German site that was all
about like 8s music and like 8s synth
pop and stuff so she uploaded it to that
and there was also a couple of other
music sites she uploaded and she's like
hey does anybody know who this is so
this little piece of the song cuz for a
while the whole song wasn't floating
around on the internet just like this
one minute portion of the song was cuz
she initially said I had the whole song
but I didn't upload it because I was
afraid of copyright that that I would
get in trouble for copyright because I
didn't know who it was so it's like so
she thought she'd be safe if it was just
like a portion of it or whatever so she
just uploaded that if you got a
copyright strike that'd be a clue to who
it is they would know well yeah never
happened though this is a okay go ahead
Danny Rowling said uh they kind of
sounded like the 80s band The Jet
blackberries oh maybe I don't well I
don't know i' I I haven't heard much of
their stuff so I can't really say but
they it's just it bothers me because
it's like they sound kind of familiar a
lot of stuff sounded like that but a lot
of stuff sounded like that yeah you know
what I mean um the vocals sound like
Dave vanan from the damed slightly kind
of but that's clearly not Dave vanan
like he sounds it's that same kind of
vocal style yeah yeah yeah Liliana says
hello first time catching one of your
streams see so that's what happens when
we accidentally do well we didn't
accidentally do a different night we
just had to do tonight cuz I was out of
town last night um big fan of your Toms
of Terror reviews well thank you very
much I really like doing those I really
need to finish I'm in the middle of um
slooh foot by Braum and I really have to
finish reading that because I have to
review it but I haven't had a lot of
time I'm also reading the um the uh Rob
howford biography autobiography which is
actually quite good um the early AI
music yeah that's what Ben said
ironically if she got a copyright claim
it might give a lead exactly but it's
like as far as I know nobody ever cuz a
lot of people have posted the full song
now I just got it off um archive.org
like it's pretty easy to find on there a
bunch of people have uploaded it YouTube
and and the copy that we have came off
that tape M it's it's ridiculous but
it's it's actually must have been a
pretty good quality tape recorder
because the recording sounded pretty
good through yeah I mean I'm not sure if
somebody's cleaned it up over the years
or whatever yeah uh yeah Zach said could
have just been this is what I thought
too some upand cominging band that wind
up going nowhere and I have no idea
what's happening or they're dead which
sucks so bad yeah that's what I think is
yeah that's kind of maybe and this is
and I have a feeling this is their only
song it was some kind of demo they made
yeah maybe so yeah yeah Liliana said
awesome I just bought sloot H yeah I
bought it not too long ago I just
haven't got a chance of finish it yet uh
and I just finished womb I really liked
that book if you're into extreme horror
I really liked wom I also have a feeling
that this band never toured or never
played live no probably not because I
think people would have heard it and go
oh I know who those are you would think
at least one person in the [__] world
like on the internet would right I think
that's why people are so intrigued by
this because everything else there's
somebody out there that remembers that
[__] you know what I mean especially I
mean 1984 wasn't that long ago I still
kind of remember it so you know what I
mean I mean yeah it was a long time ago
but not so long ago that everybody that
would remembered as dead you know what I
mean the Soviet Union and the Soviet
satellite states were still in in in
place this is I think this is
something I think this is something kind
of Soviet sphere I I that's just my it
might be that's what I think it is
Liliana said what's the name of the song
nobody knows exactly um Mo mostly if you
search the most mysterious song on the
internet it usually comes up I've seen
it called like the wind I've seen it
called Blind the wind um I've seen it
called what was the other title that I
said was
um something like and this was just I
don't even know why it would be called
this but it was just because um it was
supposedly in The Meta metadata but
check it in check it out I don't know
why it would be called that necessarily
might be the name of the band yeah maybe
I don't know cuz I can't I can't really
like discern all the words it is in
English yeah but I can't really discern
all the lyrics it sounds foreign it does
well like I said it's in English but it
sounds like slightly accented English
yeah so so yeah so this little minute
long snippet of the song is kind of
starts floating around on the internet
because like I said the sister of the
guy that had recorded it originally she
put it up on a bunch of like forums of
80s music like trying to identify it so
this guy named Nicholas uh Zuniga I
guess is how you pronounce this or
Zuniga who worked for uh dead wax
records which is like an independent
label and they were kind of um their big
thing was Post Punk and synth pop and
everything like that so he heard it and
he was like wow that's actually a good
song and he wanted to also figure out
who it was so he kind of like started
investigating trying to figure out who
it was again nobody seemed to have any
idea about anything now um it seems that
this this portion of the song was
uploaded to YouTube a little while later
probably about 2011 I think was the
earliest upload to Youtube but it didn't
really get that many views like it
didn't really take off you know what I
mean however several years later I
Believe In Spring of
2019 um this 16-year-old kid from uh sou
Paulo Brazil yeah he was super into even
though he was 16 years old he's really
into like fields of the Nephilim and
Sisters of Mercy and stuff like that he
happened to hear it on YouTube and he
really dug it so he decided he was going
to try and like you know figure out who
it was too so he uploaded it to his
YouTube
channel um and then it's just kind of
like he also posted it over on Reddit
like on a bunch of different Reddit
communities hoping that somebody would
be able to figure it out and at that
point I guess he had enough followers or
because it went on Reddit or something
like that at that point it went viral
and everybody started like talking about
it and everybody started trying to
figure out well not everybody obviously
but like a lot of people started to
figure out try to figure out who this
was um and then I think it got another
boost when uh Wang who we've talked
about before it's a great Channel um
yeah like he decided to do a show about
it after somebody recommended it to him
it's like oh you should do like an
episode about this and it's still up on
YouTube I watched it earlier it's about
15 minutes long good episode it is a
good episode yeah it's like really
interesting and um so so at that point
you know cuz he has like a really large
audience so it kind of like you know
just went up exponentially from there um
and then somebody said well we need kind
of the whole song so the sister actually
found the original tape and digitized
the whole song and then put the song up
cuz at this point she wasn't worried
about copyright anymore so at that point
the whole song became available like I
said you can download it from anywhere I
got from archive.org but a bunch of
people have uploaded it to YouTube as
well so um so it's on Reddit it's on
Discord uh a bunch of people started
like trying to figure out who this was
um and they're trying to figure out you
you know how people do when they get
like all so they're trying to like
figure out where exactly the accent came
from they're trying to figure out all
the lyrics they're using forensics right
they're trying yeah they're doing like
forensics on it like trying to figure
out like speculating all this other kind
of stuff
um so they're thinking well this band is
maybe from Germany or maybe Austria or
Poland like somewhere like Eastern
Europe type of thing just because like I
said it's in English but the now let me
say something in this time there results
to an East
Germany and that was on the other side
of the Berlin wall and they were had a
crushing totalitarian Communist
Regime this might be from there and it
might be the work of one man and somehow
made it its way across the the Berlin
Wall if so there'd probably be no
records well that's another possibility
that um that I'm going to get into in a
minute because yeah that was that was it
does sound German to me the ACC yeah I
it does slightly but like I said it
could be Austrian it could be because
when you sing it's kind of hard to tell
exactly it's hard to pinpoint like the
only yeah the only accent that I can
reliably tell it's like if you have a
real thick accent when you're singing is
maybe like an Irish accent or maybe a
French accent I can usually tell the
strange thing about it is the is the
obscurity
yeah see which tells me that this did
not come from a music scene which makes
me think the Communist sphere somewhere
bad East Germany maybe yeah because if
it came from because usually if you're
in a band or something like that there's
other you know other musicians you play
together and there's like a whole scene
in whatever Town you're in and it's like
so you think at least if even if all of
those members of the band weren't around
anymore like somebody else would be like
oh yeah I remember those guys you know
what I mean but the fact that nobody
remembers them that leads me to believe
yet that yeah it came from somewhere
that was not right and which tells me
that I don't think there was there was
no album I think it's just this song
there was no live
shows so it was someplace where the
music was being
suppressed somehow it got into Germany
man that sounds like a situation was
happening in East Germany in '
84 yeah well like I said I'll kind of
get in because that is like a
possibility that is a possibility yeah
that's what I'm thinking I'm going go
make another drink I I wouldn't mind
like that just refresh cuz it's kind of
getting tequil says I downloaded that
devil of Nan King book he reviewed a
while back and it was great yeah I loved
that book it was really really good mooh
haer if you haven't um read it yeah
devil of Nan King it's really really
good it's [__] up but it's it's really
good but yeah so um yeah so they're
figuring out well yeah it's obviously
German or Austrian or polish or
something like at least from the
accented England
um as I mentioned earlier is this a
whole band it's just this one guy like
playing all these instruments it seemed
like they did go into a studio um and I
think that the um that the keyboard that
they used was one that was quite
expensive at the time so they either
would have had the money to get it
meaning they took the [__] seriously or
they rented a studio where you could
have access to that um you know what I
mean now so what they decided to do like
through all the investigation they said
well maybe what we should do is try to
figure out who the DJ was on this
particular radio show um that supposedly
played this song and maybe he would you
know on the off chance that he might
remember it like this many years later
right um so the they figured out that
the DJ probably that was that probably
played the song was a guy named Paul
Baskerville now he was British but he
lived in Germany at the time I don't
know know if he still but as of 2019 he
still worked at that radio station as
far as I
know um so they asked him about it like
they actually did cuz it's the internet
so they tracked his ass down and they
started asking him if he remembered it
um he did not and he's like I don't know
if I even played it on my show you know
it was a long time ago it was 1984 I
wouldn't remember a song that I played
on the radio in 1984 but you know I'm
not this guy so but he said he didn't
remember play playing it um and he said
I mean and he has a collection of like
10,000 albums like you know what I mean
it's like it could have been on any of
those um I have no idea but I don't
really when they played it for him he
didn't really remember it now he did say
that one thing he would do other than
kind of like all the like I said sort of
mainstreaming songs that he played on
the show as we were you know saying the
titles of them he said now sometimes
What would happened is that I would get
these random tapes from like Indie bands
and things like that and as as um Tom
mentioned some of them had been mailed
to him or smuggled to him from across
the Berlin Wall so that's what I was
saying earlier why that is a possibility
because the DJ did say that occasionally
he would get tape smuggled to him from
bands on the other side of the Berlin
wall and that he would play them on the
show now he doesn't have you know you
were in there but he said he the
particular DJ he's like I don't have any
memory of that song Or I don't remember
playing that but he's like that is a
possibility because I did get tapes like
that sometimes yeah that were smuggled
across or mailed to him or something
like that and he would play them um he's
like yeah he thought he didn't
necessarily think it was German like I
said he's a British guy but he lived in
Germany and might still as far as I know
but he's he thought that it was more
likely
he's like it could be German just going
from the accent in English um but he
said but it could also be polish or
Russian um so he's like I'm not really
sure um and he's like you know we had
the playlists from back then but you
know they're long gone they've long been
thrown away and he said there was
another DJ working there who he
remembered from that time period who
might have played it uh but that dude
has since passed away so we don't really
know um if because Paul Baskerville like
I said I don't even know because the
last thing that I saw that where they
were talking to him was from 2019 and at
that point he was still alive and he
still worked at that radio station but
um in Germany but he said that there was
another DJ working there in ' 84 who
might have also played it but that guy
passed away like so they don't really
know what happened like I think he died
in 2016 or something like that that's a
big clue that's a big clue when he said
that they would play stuff smuggled
across the Berlin Wall yeah yeah yeah
see that so that's what I thought was
like the most likely scenario especially
because absolutely nobody yeah
recognized it you know what I mean if it
was that you'd have a situation where
the guys in East Berlin could pick up ra
Western radio signals yeah so they could
hear the music being played in Germany
they could learn English and [__] see
the lyrical
Styles but they're kind of in a society
that has a bunch of rats that was like a
rat culture [__] East Germany if you
had any kind of Western sympathies your
neighbors would [__] report
you they had their ver they when they
when that [__] fell they went into the
archives of the um East German secret
police and they found out the damn half
of the damn population to East Germany
with bunch of rats ratting on their
[__] neighbors over stupid [__] you
know oh they you know they like this
kind of music or oh this person once
said something that made me think that
they that they like the West you know
they were rats but um so it could come
from there and it may have been one man
with like a four track or a six track
recorder thing like I said working alone
I have heard and I think you were out of
the room when I said this I have heard
that the particular style of keyboard
that was I can't remember what keyboard
it was but it was one that was quite
expensive at the time I think it was
like
$2,500 um with you which would have been
a lot of money in 194 e well well that's
another thing so you don't really know I
and I don't know if this is necessarily
true or not I don't know enough about
music engineering to say but they're
like well because this
particular um keyboard was used either
this band was like serious and they
actually could afford to buy that or
they could afford to rent Studio space
for a day or something like that and
that studio had one of those band like
that would have had fans and would would
have been record maybe it was
an Eastern
German who worked at a university or
some [__] like that that had access to
that you know what I mean where they
were doing where they had music school
because e Germans did have [__] music
state sponsored music and maybe this was
something that he did in his own time
like on the down on the down low yeah so
it didn't necessarily mean this is a guy
in his basement it might have been a guy
who was a University Music Professor or
worked you know some [__]
access to it right and just kind of like
snuck in there snuck in there and did a
song in [__] yeah you don't know it
could be anything it's mysterious [__]
man it's a great song I really like that
song actually it's um a couple bands
have covered it since then I guess you
might might as well might as well
because you know they can't bust you for
it right it was from the heart whoever
made it Zach said uh I did learn the
BG's manager cuz Zach got really into
the bgs used to send in nameless tapes
to DJs so they get radio play when they
weren't super fashionable so maybe
that's also what happened yeah maybe it
was like some oneoff of somebody that
was like kind of famous and they wanted
to do this one kind of song when you
have a song that's like
this chances are I mean something like
this would could would catch on in ' 84
yeah if there were other if there was
like off of an album people would want
to know the rest of the album and it
would have survived so there's no album
the song is is is a demo it's a single
yeah I kind of well okay and here's
another thing too and this just happened
in the last couple
years so as I said people on Reddit and
[__] like that are are investigating the
origins of this song so back in 2020 one
user on Reddit he found or he was able
to attain uh the complete list of songs
that Paul Baskerville had played on
music for young people in
1984 um or so he said and he published
it on the site now so everybody went
through it and all of the songs were
matched which means that this song was
maybe not played on that show and was
maybe played on another show which means
that we have to go back to the drawing
board so he may have t gotten this off
of another show off of another show well
because like I said the guy Darius he
did say that he was just recording stuff
off different radios that was the one
that he first thought of because that
was his favorite one and that was the
one that he recorded the most songs off
that kind of matches though because when
you talked about the other songs that
they played on that [__] in that set
right they don't have anything to do
with this this sound yeah yeah yeah like
other than maybe dep maybe the Cure in
the depes mode and maybe yeah well there
was like Malcolm McLaren was on there
and yeah but there's no telling what
that sounded like simple and early
Simple Minds was kind of more they
didn't they weren't as mainstreaming as
he claims that's the real list
yeah supposedly and and the evidence is
solid I mean he's got a piece well I
don't know I'm not really sure what how
where did he say how did he say the list
came to him xeroxed piece of paper oh
the the guy on Reddit oh I'm not really
sure but yeah so this was just like a
couple years back but he said he was
able to get the and that song wasn't on
there which doesn't mean it doesn't
exist obviously but it's just kind of
like that he's saying oh well maybe it
wasn't that radio show and maybe we need
to like look another Direction I seem to
remember remember that that German radio
show wasn't really known for keeping
records uh real well because it was just
kind of an on the spot ad hoc type of
show anyway you know what I mean well
radio stations in general I think they
they you pretty much have to like have
lists of playlists and [__] like that
because it it has to do with and I'm not
sure how Germany works but I know that
in the US like radio because you have to
pay a certain percentage like for every
okay iteration of that song that you
play so you have to keep track I
remember that they were saying that you
can't just play whatever yeah I remember
they were saying that there was a lot of
gray though in in the records for the
yeah maybe so I don't think he had to
keep it for very
long the records you know what I mean
it's not like he didn't need 40 Years of
[__] song
records because uh I remember Wang
talking about that yeah that they that
they that they didn't have any records
that's what I remember him
saying well I'm according to the DJ that
worked there I mean they did have
records but they threw them out they out
I'm saying they don't keep them right
they don't keep them CU why would they
but it's like you were supposed to keep
track of like everything that you played
because like I said it's it's a percent
I don't like I said I don't know how it
works in Europe but it's a percentage
that you pay yeah that goes out to as
soon as that shit's a couple years old
you don't need it anymore they were
throwing that [__] out from what I
remember yeah cuz why would you keep it
yeah it's just like takes up bra nobody
cares that what you played five years
ago right I mean except for for
everybody trying to figure out what this
song is they weren't they weren't
planning on this well no obviously it's
like they didn't realize that people
would want want to know what what band
this is which is kind of crazy when you
think about it way way way back in 1984
when I was 12 years old um you know
somebody somewhere played a song on the
ger on German radio and somebody
recorded it's like hey that's a pretty
catchy tune or whatever and then decades
later people like what the [__] is that
why didn't you keep what song was that
and it's just [__] crazy that it's
like that happened like that but you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
nobody was thinking I guarantee you it's
not a band not a real
band it's demo they probably don't it's
a demo song from a guy who made that and
it may be one or two guys but probably
it could be
one could be one dude made it just could
be one dude sure on the other side of
the Berlin Wall I mean that's much
easier to do nowadays but you could
still totally do it back then if you
could play all the instruments because
nobody recognizes this [__] and it
doesn't come from any kind of social
sphere is because it didn't come from a
social sphere which means East block
Eastern
block
communist probably so yeah I like it was
probably just like mailed over yeah
communist they mailed it smuggled
it say play my song you know um yeah Ben
said doesn't don't the stations pay a
set fee and it gets divided up between
artists based on number of plays yeah I
think that's kind of how it always
worked I can't remember the name of the
system I know it but I can't think of it
maybe somebody can remind me but yeah
that's what that's what they do they pay
a set fee and then it just goes out to
the artist that's another thing that
makes you think East block because
Eastern block
products weren't copyrighted and they
weren't and you could in the west play
them for free you could copy them for
free because they didn't even do
patenting here's a good
example the cz75 pistol it was a [__]
beautiful pistol it was copied over and
over again in the west because they
didn't [__] it didn't have a patent
on it it was from the Communist block
you know just the Communists made it
they didn't care if you made any profit
off of it they wouldn't sue
you so Italian companies like tanfo were
started [__] making cc75 copies which
is a
Czechoslovakian pistol but they were in
the East block at that time you could
copy anything from the commies well
that's which would mean that you could
pay any any any song you got from them
you could play it and you wouldn't have
to worry about
royalties they weren't a [__] profit
making civilization and they didn't have
the legal structure to sue
you well yeah and it's always easier to
like copy somebody else's [__] than come
up to your own [__] so yeah if if you're
not going to get in trouble for it then
most people will absolutely do that of
course so you that's why everybody
copied the AK-47 it wasn't patented well
sure you know why might as well make it
you know the commies weren't going to
come after you they didn't have a
concept of money
not as we know it yeah Ben said that's
how it works here which I'm assuming is
Australia if a business wants to play a
radio in their waiting room they're
supposed to pay the fee yeah they are um
that's why like back in the 80s and 90s
that's why musac was so popular because
that was like royalty-free or whatever
but yeah if you play a radio in your
like the doctor's waiting room or
something like that technically they are
supposed to pay that fee um that goes to
the artist because it's public um it's
public broadcast like people are hearing
it so the artists are supposed to get a
cut of that yeah but in this case if you
had an East German artist that smuggled
something across the border he wouldn't
even want any money he just want you to
pay the play his song because he wanted
it to be heard in the west yeah so yeah
and the the r in in the west German
radio station would play it happily yeah
that's their brothers on on the other
side of the wall they were trying to
reunite yeah I mean there yeah I think
it's East German I mean that to me seems
like the most likely thing that seems
like the most because if it was anything
else if it was any other you know
country back then that it was you know
if it was a British band or or something
like that like somebody would have
remembered it yeah and they would have
made more material so you go oh that's
what you call it I recognize that voice
right you know yeah the fact that nobody
recognizes any aspect of it is what's
kind of freaky to me yeah because it was
a oneof it's a s it's a
single but I mean I kind of w i kind of
hope that the person that made it is
still alive
because it would be kind of neat to be
like wow now I'm kind of famous probably
did probably dead I know sadly but east
east German uh life expectancy was
pretty low uh most of them died from
alcoholism very depressing
situation and even if the guy but then
the reunification happened in what 1990
91 somewhere around
there [__] that was more than 10 years
almost for 13 years later the guy may
have died yeah it's possible during that
time yeah half naked you said uh when
did Tom retire from the Army well I
didn't retire from the Army i' my
enlistment ran up in
94 but then uh uh I ended up kind of
entering a [__] weird world after 911
of [__] Contracting and stuff and
then uh I suffered an
injury well this is a long story and uh
ended up getting 80% disability through
the
VA so I'm I'm retired medically
retired yeah right because the injury
was such that you could not continue
your military career uh and they do [__]
in a weird way it happened retroactively
I got the VA settlement over 10 years
after the injury happened yeah
yeah well you had to they try to pay you
off they you had to jump through a lot
of Hoops yeah yeah I had jump through
some hoops but they try to pay you off
well you know
mm lawyers and [__] well you know
everybody got to get their cut yeah yeah
it's it's it's all a [__] it's all a
grift anyway the entire military
industrial complex is a [__] grift
well that's why I told you before it's
just kind of like hey if they're going
to give you money get get every single
drop out of them that they'll you why
wouldn't you everyone else does it I am
a political atheist Republicans and
Democrats those are just [__] clowns
it is all a grift all those
[__] are
grifting uh civilians need to wake up
it's a bad system very bad I'm pretty
sure everybody knows that yeah they they
know by now they're right uh half naked
you then says uh yeah so is Ryan he was
just wondering you should get extra
money now that you're married yeah yeah
that's what and we've already gone
online like on the VA thing and he
already claimed me as a dependent so
we're going to see how that works out I
think it's probably an extra 200 a month
I think I'm not really sure it's
probably done by percentage I think it's
done by percentage of like I was looking
it up and I was like well this is like
to you're looking it up she's no no no I
was well I was kind of I saw like a site
because I was looking for how you would
do it yeah and it's some like
complicated formula like what percentage
your disability is or what percentage
your punching is or whatever and it's
just kind of like and I couldn't figure
it out well I'm at 80% so it'll be
pretty good A couple hundred bucks
probably
yeah Ben says back in the day DJs and
stations would actually get paid bribes
to play music on the radio yeah there's
a word for it it's called Peola Peola
yeah um yeah uh music shops got paid
bribes to put albums prominently then
agents would buy them up to get music
awards yeah and the same thing still
happens not so much with music but um
same thing still happens I've heard
about [__] happening with um like books
like somebody will put a book out and
then like uh you know one company or
think tank or something like that will
buy like a whole bunch of them so it'll
go like to the top of the bestseller
list which will you know cause more
sales because people will see oh it's on
the best seller list so I'm going to buy
it too you know what I mean um so it's
been going on for like a really long
time it's but yeah they used to do that
I think there was a huge Scandal about
it I want to say it was the 50s there
was a huge because I think that was when
the term Peola was coined maybe in the
1950s maybe earlier but it was going on
back then too so that's obviously that's
not a new phenomenon some of you
youngsters I don't know how many
youngsters we got listening don't
understand how much money used to be in
music there's no money in it really now
but back in the day man because there
were only a few there were only a few
mediums available television
radio and in radio he had talk radio or
you had
music and back in those days a company
uh a a [__] bad was like a company
uh a band like Duran Duran all right in
the [__] late 80s would spend
millions of dollars producing a [__]
album millions they wouldn't do that
never do that today but they spend
Millions especially when you put uh the
all the video they'd have to shoot
videos and um but they would make
hundreds of millions or [__] tens of
millions out uh off of it and that
market really isn't there anymore
because YouTube and [__] Spotify and
stuff so it's different bands just
don't
command the amount of eyeballs as they
used to because everything is so
Broadband you could have a million great
bands
now back in the day if you had one or a
dozen great
bands they're only show it was it was
very narrow band you know what I mean
they would only show you maybe 12 13
things at once and they were making it a
[__] ton of money well like I said in a
way it's kind of a blessing and a curse
because back in the old days you only
had a set amount MH and everybody was
kind of seeing the same [__] like to a
certain degree and there was great [__]
back then like there and it's still good
nowadays I'm not saying that yeah but
it's like nowadays I think the problem
now I like it better now because anybody
you know pretty much anybody can put
their [__] out there but because anybody
can put their [__] out there there's so
much competition and it's so hard to
get well yeah but it's like it was back
then too but it usually got winnowed out
it's like nowadays you're just seeing
everything without the winno process so
it's just kind of like you have to Wade
through a lot of [__] it's like you
know you I'm in really into horror
movies so you go on tub it's like
there's 40 bajillion shitty $5 horror
movies you know what I mean they were
made for $5 I mean but then if you keep
looking through there like mixed in
there's like really awesome ones
and
it's unless you have curate it it's hard
find [__] out of you some of this good
[__] that she's talking about had that
come out in the 80s they would have been
huge Blockbusters I mean people right
right right Classics yeah sometimes I'm
just like wandering through tub or
wandering on YouTube and just hearing
some like random band or see some random
I'm like man that's [__] great yeah
back in the [__] back in the 8S been
like creaming their [__] jeans over
there and it's like now it's like nobody
notices because so much stuff there so
much stuff but um a lot of younger
people are going back into the 80s and
90s and listening to classic American
and British bands um and they're saying
boy this music was so much better back
then it was it was it was a different
time the market was very different
things were crafted differently and the
uh it was
deeper even the um fairly commercial
stuff like dur Duran had a meaning
behind it you could relate to it uh it
wasn't some it wasn't very vapid a lot
of the [__] you find some of the [__]
was like sometime sometimes I hear [__]
from the like I was listening to other
day um some of Madonna stuff like from
the'80s and I was like wow this is
annoying as [__] yeah some of it but
Madonna if you ask me was never good I
didn't realize I liked her real early I
lik lucky star and I like like into the
groove and [__] like that but it's like
some like um like Material Girl and
stuff like I'm like this is a terrible
song as far as Mega bands went though
though I always liked Duran Duran I like
all their content yeah I was really into
that I mean you got a really like you go
on the notorious
album um and and they were [__]
famous they were real famous at that
time you're listening to that [__]
it's it's a whole album about hookers
and blow a whole album about hookers
they writing from personal experience
sure yeah and girls who were [__]
turning themselves out for cash in
college and it's just like I can't
believe they were doing this [__] in the
late ' 80s and getting away with it but
you really had to kind of read between
the lines of what they were talking
about and um you know just it was just
great music you know Danny rling said
Talking Heads are good they are yeah I
really like talking I really like
Talking Heads yeah I like a lot yeah I
like a lot of
different but but I'm not saying I don't
want to romanticize it too much because
there was a lot of crap in the 80s too a
lot of crap it's just that nowadays it's
been so many decades like all the bad
[__] people kind of forget about it or
they just listen to it ironically or
whatever and just like really only the
good [__] is like the stuff that people
remember so I think that's another thing
too that's why I don't think it's
necessarily completely untrue that it's
like music and movies and [__] like that
were better back then but there's also a
kind of thing where you don't have
enough perspective on stuff that's
coming out now um you know because it
some stuff like just came out or it's
new so you don't have like Decades of
looking back on and be like oh yeah that
really stood the test of time like you
won't know until like 20 or 30 years
down the line so I try not to I always
said like when I was even when I was a
teenager said I never want to be one of
those people that's like back in my day
like [__] was so much better and blah
blah like I don't want because that's
not true that's never true like in any
era so because you're you're just
getting cuz I feel like nowadays you're
just getting the perspective of here's
all the good [__] from all the decades
that have gone by like it's been curated
for you to a degree because only the
good [__] kind of survives so you know
the stuff that's coming out now doesn't
have that um weight behind it yet
because it hasn't been long enough like
we don't know if it's going to have any
staying power or not and there might be
stuff that comes out now that people are
like H that sucked and then like 20
years from now like oh my God that was
[__] brilliant and like nobody
noticed it because it's like we talked
about that before like when The Shining
came out in 1980 when the thing came out
in 1982 like The Shining was nominated
for Razzy awards for [__] sake and it
was Stanley kubri um the thing like went
nowhere it was kind of a flop and but
now this many decades later like
everybody's like oh my God it was a
[__] classic yeah but younger
audiences liked it they did they did but
it wasn't enough to like push it over
like it took a while for it to the thing
with the old music was is that the
stakes were higher back then and the
real talented bands really [__] had
wellth thought out [__] but it wasn't
just 880s it went back the 70s too you
know Zach is a big [__] BS fan for
disco man [__] BS were the [__] yeah
I unironically like the
be they're a good band it's beautiful I
didn't like it at the time like when I
was younger it was so overplayed because
yeah because we heard it all the time
and I was like okay enough with the
Disco yeah and it was kind of like the
generation before us yeah it was it was
like Dad music a little Al my dad wasn't
super I listen to that [__] now and I go
[__] oh yeah like oh yeah that was
good that's just [__] awesome cuz
like I said you have more perspective on
it now because you're not hearing it all
the time and it's like oh it's my dad's
music or whatever so it's like
that uh Juan Ortiz Velasquez says hi Tom
and Jen how are you uh we're doing
pretty awesome thank you very much for
asking um so yeah so there okay so about
this particular song like a lot of um
rumors and theories went because you
know it's like they posted on Reddit so
everybody's going to come up with some
like [__] or they're going to be like
oh I knew the guy that did that you know
everybody's going to like makeup stories
and stuff so one person posts and
they're like oh um I'm a friend of this
band and I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
this right but it was like kind of this
obscure German band I think that were
called I iser iser something like that
um said oh it was a friend of theirs uh
the song is actually called check it in
it came out in 1982 but the lead singer
is dead now so that's what somebody said
I don't know if that's true or not they
probably just pulled that out their ass
um and then there were somebody also
posted I think on on Reddit that um yeah
this was the this band they were from uh
East Berlin and they this was the last
song they recorded before they tried to
escape to West Berlin and they all got
shot I was like yeah like so I was like
well you might want to if you're going
to make up a story you might want to
dial it back a little bit I mean I'm not
saying that couldn't have happened it
absolutely could have but I doubt it
it's very I do think they're from East
Germany that to me that seems the most
likely scenario like I said just because
nobody no fans yeah because nobody
really remembers it and that's like kind
of and that's a good song like I said
it's not it's funny because they asked
Paul Baskerville who was the DJ that
supposedly might have played it like the
British guy that uh you know lived in
Germany at the time and he says this was
a quote from him when they asked him
about it he said I don't want to sound
like a traitor to the cause but I don't
know what all the fuss is about if I
thought it was the best thing since
sliced bread I probably would be more
interested but I don't think it's a
particularly interesting song
So DJs are kind of um they're [__]
they're kind of [__] they're [__]
yeah we we know several now now yeah
yeah they b i I will say I I do know we
do know one DJ that is a delightful
delightful person but most um most DJs
are sher's awesome oh yeah yeah okay so
we know two so we know two you know the
other one I'm talking about so we know
two DJs that are actually you know what
I I kind of take that back cuz now I'm
thinking of like other DJs that I know
I'm like oh well okay not all [__]
Mark's great yeah maybe I'm just
thinking of maybe I'm just thinking of
like it's just it's just I'm just
thinking of like a couple that I know
it's not personal thing it's just DJs
have the opinions about music sure
that's all it is yeah and and they're
very strong opinions which okay I have
strong opinions less strong opinions
that I used to have because I'm just
kind of like look man it's just and I
you know you do you I'm not going to
[__] on other people's musical taste or
movie taste or anything like that
because everybody likes different [__]
and it's dumb saying it's like oh well
you know that sucks across the board I'm
like well [__] like that is subjective
so no what's what's this DJ's name
Baskerville Paul Baskerville yeah okay
what he's saying is he's saying at the
time he didn't really notice this s
right right right uh but he doesn't see
it through our eyes he's older than us
this song has aged well yeah okay and
really uh it it it's a tight song and it
does kind of nail a certain aesthetic
that goth people like like that yeah
like that's yeah we hear [__] like that
like all our little our all our little
happy so like who is that is there more
of that's our little back in his day
there would have been a lot of bands
like this and this would have been new
and kind of experimental and maybe like
a little try hard and like nothing
really outstanding so that's what he's
that's what he's saying yeah like it
didn't stand out at the time which I
guess it wouldn't have because like I
said there were a lot of bands sounded
like that from this from his point of
view this would have been all the new
upand cominging guys would have sounded
like this and you don't really like how
they sound right that that's what he
would have been like imagine like
everybody sounding like no doubt all
[__] just showing up out of
for yeah everybody sounds like [__]
no doubt yeah although I [__] love
Gwen Stefani and no doubt I [__] I
love I liked him at the time but when I
hear him now I don't like him I still
love they were I I lik '90s music also
it just it had its own thing it's own
gal it did but like I told you it's like
I'm not once the '90s came along it's
like there was something about it that
just kind of rubbed me the wrong way
there was a lot of good 90s music oh
yeah I'm not saying that switch play
Symphony yeah yeah yeah I'm not saying
but that was kind of that was like more
of like a niche thing like a lot of the
mainstream music from the 90s just kind
of like got on my nerves there was a lot
of good '90s Dead Can Dance yeah yeah
I'm not talking about that necessarily
right you're talking about the
mainstream go yeah yeah the mainstream
well you know prodigy
which was kind of coming out of nowhere
okay yeah smack my [__] up you know
okay um Marilyn man I'll dance to that
if I'm drunken of I don't really like
Marilyn Manson like the only the only
songs I like of his are like the covers
he did like those are okay but other
than that I was just like I said it all
just seemed very tryhard it was of its
of its day yeah it the 90s just seemed
like the try hard decade it was it was
and that just bugged me cuz I'm like
stop trying to be cool stop trying to be
hard stop trying to be edgy it's just
like just be what you want to be like
garbage came out I do like garbage
[__] garbage was great Shirley Manson
[__] you know who's kind of almost
forgotten now it's a shame she did great
James Bond covers [__] um just good
videos uh I like to go Massive Attack
was also good yeah they were good they
were good right oh I need to put some
more of that on my Spotify you asked
poris head I forgot yeah I like yeah I
like poris head so the ' 90s was not not
a bad time for music no no no I just
didn't like it as much because I didn't
like the aesthe one thing that I like
about' 80s music and I think maybe why a
lot of younger people like are into' 80s
music now is because it's not a lot of
80s music is very um Earnest like they
weren't trying over the top to be cool
or edgy or anything like that they were
just kind of singing about their genuine
emotion and they didn't really care if
it sounded cheesy or whatever and I kind
of like that better than being like o
look what a bad ass I am or look what
like that kind of [__] just pisses me
off um I kind of just wish because
because it just comes off as fake you
know what I'm saying like it's a pose
and I don't really like anything that
comes off as a pose you know if you're
weird and you're just making music
that's weird and it comes across as
genuine because you're genuinely a weird
person that I'm going to be into that
but if you're just pretending to be a
weird person because you think that's
what's going to sell then then then it's
really obvious and it just comes across
as fake and I don't like it Ben says the
AI movies are coming uh no AI movies are
not coming AI movies have been here for
a long time uh according to my sources
inside Hollywood fing but no uh ai ai is
writing scripts they cut and paced
[__] and they just kind of pick
through there's a human involved but
well like I said I have a subscription
to an AI writing thing and if you just
tell it to write a script about whatever
it's not great no you got to pick
through it you have to really go through
there so it has to still be human
directed I think it will still be a long
time before AI can absolutely come up
with like a good story on its own um
because what I noticed I was curious
like I said to see what would happen so
I gave it um kind of an outline and I
said I want to see would like write a
novel like you know based on this
outline that I put up there and it
was okay but one thing that I noticed
that it did a lot was it kept repeating
[__] like it would do like a series of
scenes and I'm like oh that's okay you
know it still needs tweaking obviously
um it's like that's all right but then
you go to the next chapter and it was
basically like the same [__] again but
like just written in a slightly
different way so it was just it kept
like repeating the same kind of [__]
over and over again so you really
definitely do need a human to still like
curate that [__] seriously yeah now I
don't know I don't know if Brian is
[__] uh I know he's online I don't
know if he's in the comment section but
no Brian hacket said his buddy of mine
he worked on [__] drag through
concrete he says AI scripts have been
been around for a long time yeah yeah
yeah well like I said I've used AI um
for like prompts like cuz sometimes like
I cuz I have like a third of an Al
written and so like sometimes you go in
there and you get stuck and you can go
in there to Ai and be like okay well
whatever I have written thus far write
me the next paragraph and then you and
then it'll give you a couple of options
and they're not fantastic you still but
it'll give you like an idea and you can
fix it you know what I mean so that's
kind of my has been my experience we
liked any music or friends yeah hold on
I'm kind of behind Okay um Zach's
talking about the bgs I like their 60s
stuff more uh they were doing
psychedelic Rock and Soul Back in the
day and it's gorgeous yeah they did do a
lot of good [__] back then like I said
everybody was kind of getting into dis
into disco in the 70s um Danny rling
said I'm all about Vaudeville music said
nobody
ever then bed said V well yeah
Vaudeville wasn't just about music it
was performance magic tricks dancing
comedy yeah it was like a whole
entertainment thing it was television on
stage um Kayon hickin said have you guys
ever heard of the internet mystery
behind cicada 3301 um ironically I was
actually going to talk about that on
this show I might or I might not um I
was going to initially and then I was
like well I don't know I don't want the
show to be like six hours long we could
always do another one of these shows
later yeah I do have notes for that like
down so if we get to it and I feel like
it we might but I kind of feel like a
lot of people have covered that and to
me it's not quite as creepy as like or
as interesting as some of the other
stuff but you know what I mean but it is
kind of interesting though I'm just
saying um Ben says Charles Manson was a
better musician than Marilyn Manson
Charles Manson was actually pretty good
according to he was actually which I
hate to say but cuz you know cuz he's a
terrible person
um mle said do you guys like any of the
music that your parents Listen to I used
to hate my mother playing Motown as a
kid but I actually like it now yeah I
think when you get to a certain age it's
just kind of like um I didn't really
have that to too much of a degree
because I grew up when I was a little
kid my dad was like super super into the
Beatles And so I got really into the
Beatles too and I
never rejected that because it was my
dad's music I just thought it was good
you know what I mean I liked a lot of I
liked the Beatles I liked the doors I
liked a lot of his albums I didn't like
all of it like he liked the Eagles and
Leonard skinnard and stuff and I wasn't
really into that but um but I did like
the Beatles and the doors and he had
like a couple Kinks albums and I like
those but um so yeah so I didn't really
have a problem with liking stuff that my
dad liked my dad was weird he didn't
like music some people don't I've met a
couple people like that drive around in
a [__] truck with the [__] radio
off he wouldn't even listen to the radio
he just like lik silence he only liked
one
artist Roy orberson oh I love Roy orb
yeah he liked Roy orbon that was it and
that was like he he got a taste for Roy
orberson when he was a kid so I I I went
back and listened to Roy orberson see
what he was talking about it's just
[__] kind of old goth music in a
certain way everything's kind of
downbeat and yeah I have a bunch of Ro
on my yeah he was kind of the original
goth I have a I have a massive
massive Spotify playlist I think it's
like a week long like it's however hour
however many hours a week is it's that
long so I could listen to it for a week
without repeating a song and um there's
there's a lot of royal orent on there
well I like a lot of um I also like a
lot I like a lot of old blues music I
like a lot of 50s
rockabilly um that kind of [__] I like
some 60s music I like all kind of [__]
really yeah you know but um but yeah I
don't I don't have a thing about I maybe
did when I was a teenager like when I
was first getting into or maybe a
pre-teen when I was first getting into
like new wave and stuff then it was like
oh you know that's old people music or
whatever but I didn't really have that
too much and my mom listened to the
worst [__] possible the 70s she like
like Captain Captain and tal and [__]
weird [__] keep [__] Muskrat Love
Muskrat Love I remember that and [__]
yeah that's pretty horrible I I never
got never got a taste for that it was
like super
cheesy some cheesy [__] is good I even
appreciate like some Abba and stuff like
that
but all that kind of 70s like easy
listening kind of stuff I can't get into
that I can't get into all that Yacht
Rock kind of I can't I can't get in yeah
and it's once the 70s were was over
there that particular generation stopped
listening to music all together they did
they just stopped but there was so much
good [__] there's so much good [__]
nowadays there's good [__] everywhere
it's like you just you got to look to
find it but what was the name of that
[__] dude that did the [__] song
about [__] uh Lola was a dancer
[__] Barry man Barry Mano she was
bigger than Barry Manalo I was like I
gotta Barry man I okay I don't mind
Barry manow actually I mean I'm not
going to listen to like a whole album or
anything but it's like one song I'd be
like all right all right yeah I can't
really with the captain and tal a lot of
people had that album though it wasn't
really that weird because I think my
parents had it too my mom's like not
real into music the only artist I
remember her really liking was Kenny
roggers which I couldn't get into that
but that was like the only tapes I
remember being in her car whereas my dad
like I said was way more he had like a
ton a ton of Records but he was super
into the Beatles he liked the Rolling
Stones too um Kinks he liked a lot of
like southern rock um he liked cream um
yeah I'm trying to think of like all the
other stuff he had he had like a zillion
[__] records but then like when the
80s came along he kind of got into like
he like he even like when I started
listening to Duran Duran like he liked a
lot of that he liked Van Halen like all
that kind of stuff so I haven't seen him
in a while so I don't know what he's
going now but um but yeah so so I didn't
really have a weird thing about oh
that's my parents music you know what I
mean I wasn't that bad about that cuz I
was like Hey The Beatles were probably
the first band I got into because it was
always on in the house when I was little
and I really liked it so because it was
always my dad was always playing music
so I didn't really have a have a issue
with it that weird generational thing
and like I said my dad was pretty open
to my music too and he's like oh hey
this is pretty good you know what I mean
so he wasn't weird about it so which I
think is good because there's good music
like I said from every era you can't get
all like [__] wrapped up in
and I'm glad that that's kind of
disappeared I think Gen X which is you
know what we are I think that was kind
of the last generation that had that
generation gap like between you and your
parents where your parents were like
what the [__] I don't even know what
planet you're from like I feel like
that's disappeared to some degree we can
talk to people in their 20s and [__]
just we well that's what I mean and
that's why I said now it's like not
weird for us to have friends that are
like half our age and like we don't
think about it because they're all
they're into the same [__] as us they're
they and they've seen all the old movies
and they like all the old music and [__]
like that so you can just talk to them
like you could talk to somebody your own
age and they know what you're talking
about so you know what I mean so I think
that's kind of cool and maybe that's not
maybe that doesn't carry across the
board like for people that aren't into
the same [__] as us yeah like are and B
and all that kind of [__] does yeah I'm
not sure I don't know but um but in our
scene there's people from you know 18
all the way up to 60 pretty much maybe
older and they're all into the same [__]
so you can talk to them about music or
movies or whatever and they know guys
they're [__] 21 and they know more
about [__] ' 80s 90s goth than I know
[__] well that's how we met one of
our yeah that's how we met one of our
friends Nick who I think is 21 we saw
him at mannequins and he had like a he
looked all death Rock he had like the
big hair and he had like a Christian
death shirt on and I was just like we
need to go meet that kid cuz I could
tell he was young yeah he and Aaliyah
was with him later on we we saw
everything about everything he was all
we saw him at the zyx concert remember
he was yeah they were yeah they were
that was after he broke up with her yeah
but it's like so that kind of blows my
mind I was telling my brother about that
the other day I said well I know like 20
21 22 year old kids that know more about
[__] that are all into like Alien Sex
Fiend and Christian death and Joy
Division and all that kind of [__] they
know all that [__] asking me what I
should what he should listen it's new to
them so it's like they're super into it
and I was like I think that's pretty
cool you know the names all the [__]
guys in the band and everything yeah
yeah yeah and I was like I think that's
pretty cool cool yeah well I was kind of
doing the same thing with 70s music when
I was in my metal face same that's what
I mean all the [__] members of
[__] the old you go resarch Black
Sabbath and [__] [__] gezer Butler
and all those guys well [__] I mean I
got into when I was a teenager I got
into the Velvet Underground and that was
before my time and the Stooges that was
before I was born but I was really into
it so I went and researched it you know
yeah Stooges were great that was back
when [__] Detroit Rock was really
good yeah I like all that stuff M that's
all gone now yeah you had all that kind
of cool [__] yeah I love all that stuff
any anything that has to do with like
Proto Punk or you know uh and then like
the Post Punk that happened like I love
all that stuff anything that sounds like
that I'm into um but yeah so uh spoiler
alert like I said ever a lot of people
have covered the song I believe it is on
Spotify I can't remember what title it's
under actually I should probably look
because I can add it to my playlist um
but it still to this day nobody has
identified what this [__] song is and
everybody is flipping out about it
because like I said it seems like
nowadays you can find out any
information you want to know like in
seconds and the fact that no
[__] on Earth seems to
know what the song is or who did it is
just mind-blowing it's a
mind-blowing development in the modern
era yeah in the modern era it's and I
think that's why millions of people have
tried to figure out who the [__] what
the [__] and nobody has any leads on
anything it's and that's crazy to me
that's crazy to me it's got to be East
German that's the only thing that makes
sense to me I mean East German are
communist
block there was no Bann it was a demo
that a dude made with he had access
maybe he was in the University he had
access to that
keyboard and he he made a western style
song and had it smuggled across the
[__] border that's what I think it is
yeah and was good if he was in the west
and had a band and [__] could hang
out in the scene maybe he would have
grown into something you know torn
around the
clubs and it was a new sound for this
time that sound is a new sound for that
era not yeah that was like I said in '
84 that would have been slightly at
least in the US I'm not sure about
Germany but a bit ahead in the US that
would have been a little bit underground
yeah that have been avard sound in8
before cuz I I don't remember it super
clearly cuz I was pretty young but I do
remember the songs that came out that
era so that would have been a little bit
underground yeah Ben said Kenny Rogers
is better than Kenny Loggins I will give
you that I will give you that I do kind
of like the Gambler so what else is
known about this that's about it that's
about it tell I tell you what Jen what
play a little bit more of it play well I
have to start the whole thing over yeah
start the whole thing over's we're going
to hear it again again I want to hear
that song again okay well we're going to
start it over hope
it's
take
[Music]
Noor there's
no this a good song I mean you can play
this uh yeah
at Barella yeah I'm going request this
[Music]
[__] yeah is he saying like the wind I
think he's saying blind the wind it does
sound like blind the wind although that
doesn't really make sense he's not an
imish
[Music]
speaker
the that's
a pass the wind oh why you got to ruin
it like
that
now that's all I'm going to
hear I still haven't forgiven you for
like when we were listening to that this
Echo the Buton c one time and you were
like pass
the you
[__] my favorite ruined it you
ruined
[Music]
it all right that's right
Elizabeth Jack said this is most CLE I
heard I got it off I got the M um mp3
off of AR it's
everywhere I didn't do
anything yeah I like it like I said
that's that's my aesthetic I like
anytime I hear songs like that my little
ears go yeah that's you know that's just
this ended up becoming the goth sound
the prototype of the go was this Lynwood
Sly said happy birthday Jenny thank you
very much uh congratulations on the
marriage uh also thank you for that yeah
that's been how long ago is about couple
days couple days couple weeks couple
weeks that long okay yeah what you sick
of it already no I'm I'm not even
thinking about it that's funny it's all
just
normal oh my god um okay so where was I
uh Danny rolling said where's that
raccoon commercial break like yeah that
we should probably do that um and then
Bridget Harrison said more I hear it it
does sound like one guy I mean it might
be it's possible and then Zach said I
wonder if you isolated the vocals and
put them through one of those AI
enhancers it would make it easier to
understand it might like I can kind of
understand some of the words but I think
somebody has put the lyrics online but
I'm not sure what they are exactly Danny
rling said it sounds yeah it sounds like
the song um love under will by the jet
blackberries from The Return of the
Living Dead soundtrack that's where I've
heard that okay I'm going to have to go
back can listen to that song now and see
maybe that's what I'm maybe that's
what's pinging my radar cuz I just
watched that movie not too long ago it's
not that bad though well no but I mean
but that might be what it's reminding me
of because we just watched that movie
not long ago Lynwood Sly said Durand
Duran's cool uh in the 80s underrated
like most one hit wers artists like uh D
killed JFK Morrison Jimmy and King yeah
okay I'm not really sure what all that
means but
yeah um but yeah so if anybody knows
anything about this song I'm sure people
would appreciate this mystery being
solved or would they I think it's more
fun when it's mysterious no it would be
nice to know who this was I I would like
to know who this because then they'd
have this [__] [__] on Spotify with
the proper name of who it is what the
name of the song is and we would know
the backstory I got a feeling it's East
German yeah in which case we might never
know yeah and it's not a bad it's it's a
single guy I
think where is that where is that
raccoon thing there it is where is that
[Music]
rapon we haven't showed that in a while
well because we haven't been doing The
Haunting shows for a few weeks so we
haven't really had much uh we haven't
had much cause to do where that raccoon
but I do love that I still want to do
one of that of Cody being like man said
it would be
okay or man said I don't have to man I
don't have to listen to you right isn't
that what he said something like that
what's up Sly how you been I'm gonna
have to get a gift of that so yeah um so
this is one that's unsolved okay so this
next mystery also a little bit unsolved
I have theories about this but we'll get
into that so this case is known as the
jack is it fro or free I'm not sure
emails so this guy back in
2011 this dude who was 32 at the time he
died unexpectedly from a arhythmia um I
will note that he was also uh quite
overweight so I don't really know but 32
that's still pretty young to die from
something like that he died very
suddenly apparently nobody expected
it um so he
dies and uh he was apparently like a a
really fun guy like one of those kind of
Larger than Life type of dudes like you
know really into he's just a funny guy
you know what I mean so he dies now six
months almost 6 months after he
died
um people in his
family started receiving emails that
were ostensibly from him which is uh a
little weird because he's
dead now all of the messages that were
sent there weren't a [__] ton of them
but they were sent to like different
people and they were very specific and
they alluded to very specific things
that had happened since he died and
things that the family and friends
thought that like possibly nobody
outside could have known about so
whoever this is that's sending them I
don't know if it's necessarily a ghost
sending emails but whoever it is that's
sending
them had to know a lot about him about
his personal life and about his
interactions like with other people like
other and people in his family and his
friends and stuff um for example
um he had a
friend uh whose last name was Hart
and this this guy got an email like I
said it was about six months after he
died and this email said at first it
said I'm watching that was the subject
line which is a little alarming and
because he saw like who it was from and
he's like um so he's dead and like the
the subject line says I'm watching and I
think I'd probably wet my pants at that
point and then the the message said did
you hear me I'm at your house clean your
[__] attic that's what the message
said and Hart is like that's [__]
weird because not too long after like
before he
died he had been over at his house and
he was like talking
about um the attic and it's like oh I'm
thinking about turning into a bedroom or
something like that and they were joking
about how gross his attic was like how
dirty it was like it was all covered
with dust and stuff and so the fact that
he gets this email that says clean your
[__] attic um and he's like and I'm
pretty sure we were the only people in
the house when that conversation
happened so he didn't know how anyone
else would have known about it you know
what I mean weird so he thought that was
like pretty weird that he had gotten
this thing about like the joke that they
made I'm sure everybody's addict is
dirty sure well see that's what I'm
saying it's like it could be that it
could be that um so it's like uh there
was another thing like he had a cousin
named Jimmy mcra and Jimmy mcra thank
you very much Lynwood Sly that's very
nice of you very nice of you thank you I
love the little the little pear or
whatever it is like the little aerobic
peir yeah um but yeah so we had a cousin
named Jimmy McGrath now Jimmy mcra like
and this was after uh Jacka died broke
his
ankle and he was in bed like recovering
and he gets an email also from
Jack
and the the email says hey Jim how you
doing I knew you were going to break
your ankle I tried to warn you you got
to be
careful which again the dude have broken
his ankle
after the dude died and then he got this
email from this supposedly dead dude
that says that which is pretty
creepy um so it's like I don't know like
now according to his family and friends
everybody that received an email from
this guy like after he died they don't
know if it's actually him sending it or
if it's just somebody [__] with them
or something like that but they all seem
to be pretty chill about it because
they're just kind of like well if it
really is him
then that's cool that means he wants to
like stay connected with us and [__]
like that if it's not then we're just
going to it's almost kind of like
they're like we're just going to pretend
it is because it makes us feel better
they kind of are saying [__] like that
so the fact that he knew about the ankle
the fact that he knew about the attic um
is pretty weird now
obviously I'm not you know I I don't
really believe in ghosts and I don't
believe that ghost can send email s from
the afterlife cuz that would be pretty
weird I know it's happened like on a few
occasions but there I don't know I just
feel like there's like a lot of other
explanations for this maybe
because if somebody knew his password
right I mean you could just go in there
and like write
emails just to [__] with people right
like you could they could be a prank
like now all of the friends and stuff
and family and stuff say we wouldn't do
that like that would be shitty but I
don't know if I quite believe that I I
don't know if I quite believe that might
be a family member I mean yeah it would
have to be because it would have to be
somebody that knew enough about him and
about the other [__] that was going on
like to know enough to say that stuff
you know or a friend of his and this is
a setup he says if I ever anything ever
happens to me he didn't know he was
going to die though did he no it was
sudden it was sudden and he was young he
was only 32 yeah so it's not like
something he would it's unlikely that it
would be something he'd set up with
somebody yeah it's a family member well
a lot of people have thought that maybe
it was his mom or maybe his wife yeah um
wife sounds likely because she Pro maybe
would have known that kind of [__] so
I'm would and would have known the
password maybe maybe although yeah it's
that's the yeah I guess some like
married couples like I don't think I
don't know your passwords to [__] but
it's I'm not really might written down
I'm not that bothered about it I don't
even I don't even remember my [__]
password the password to the [__]
Wi-Fi it's written right there on that
pie of paper so maybe he had the right
but I don't like I said you know you
might not know my email password I don't
even remember I don't even remember my
email passw die and going through all
this [__] place I could probably find
your email password written down on a
[__] piece of paper might something I
well I didn't write it down
though then I find all your other
boyfriends find all their yeah I'm like
what the [__] man my my stable of
stallion whole stable of stallions and
[__] all these Chads your
Dre what's that in your dreams she got
all these I'm like the most boring
person
everon and all these [__] SOS [__]
just uh you you
wish I wish
that she said I was well what I like
wild [__] but it didn't have to be that
wild well I mean yeah so if you die
who's who's how many girlfriend friends
am I going to find like
30 like 30 you know all of
them no I met current ones I know about
all the old ones yeah so that's yeah
that's what I'm saying but it's like
yeah I don't no every girlfriend I got
[__] on the back burner [__] you
know all about her we're we're trying to
recruit this
[Laughter]
[__] but yeah I'm just saying that it's
like even if you went through my email
it's nothing exciting no I don't do
anything without you I'll [__] let
you know what's up I wouldn't do
anything without you we're we're a
[__] team you talking about yeah
exactly exactly that's why like I said
you better not have married me than like
running off doing [__] like that you
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that
either I just don't do that kind of but
have happened already that's yeah
exactly yeah well that's why we figured
finally yeah it might as well it's like
might as well yeah one of us wanted to
run off we would have done it by now it
would have happened already it was a
long time yeah but yeah so another
person that got an email from this guy
was um
I think it was another was it another
cousin of his his name was Frank but
they called him
Rock and he got an email that said um
well
actually okay so the ghost supposedly
I'm just using that as a lose term so
the ghost supposedly like tries to send
the email to rock but he said his
[__] email didn't work so he sends it
to somebody else and like tells it a
forward at him tell Rock great song that
was what the message said and when they
asked uh Rock about it he said you know
what's crazy is that ever since Jack
died I've been having dreams about him
and it's like after he died I was trying
to because he was a musician and he's
like and I was trying to write a song
like a tribute song to him and I was
having a hard time with the guitar part
and then I had this dream where he was
in the dream and he like showed me the
guitar part and then I figured it out
he's like so I kind of so I finished the
song and then he got this mysterious
email from this supposedly dead person
um that said great song like he had
heard it you know what I mean so I
thought that was a little bit weird too
like I said I absolutely positively 100%
don't really believe in ghosts but um
that's pretty weird that's pretty weird
so so there's that so there's all these
emails that he's sending that where he
seems to know like all this
information now um as I said his friends
and family seem pretty chill about all
of this um they're just like if it's
really him then awesome uh we like that
he's still talking to us and [__] like
that if it's not we're just going to
pretend it is because like I said it
makes us feel better which is fine
that's their
prerogative um now if this is someone
else doing this for whatever reason
because it's not like it was an ongoing
thing it's just like he sent a bunch of
emails like at varying times like about
6 months after he died and then nobody
because when when he got like the emails
from when they got um the emails from
him like obviously they tried to reply
like hey Jack how's the afterlife or
whatever Pooky pooky's on the show yeah
she's a guest now you be a guest you
going to be a guest Pooky what have you
had to say about that do you believe in
ghosts she's like I'm too fat to believe
in ghosts would you shut up with the
fat you're going to give her a complex
you getting
fat she's like I don't give a [__] yeah
she she's care she doesn't care no she
doesn't care that's status she's like
eat cats get fat they're like yeah
[__] right that's right [__] look at
this
belly yeah wa she does she doesn't care
it doesn't matter she's just cute yeah
you're just cute and round yeah we love
you the way you are mommy loves you the
way you are yeah not sure about
daddy I'm just kidding um but yeah's
worried about your health she's yeah
she's all right she's not that over
she's okay she hasn't been eating as
much now because bam bamb eats all her
food and Bambi's like really skinny yeah
but she's like a [__] she will eat
whatever you put down she doesn't care
what it is she's just like plows right
through it I'm like that wasn't for you
okay she's already eaten all of it but
okay um but yeah so uh so the family
members and friends like try to
reply you know and be like hey what's up
how's the afterlife or whatever but they
never got a response which to me again
that kind of leans more
toward maybe this is a hoax of some kind
not really sure what the motivation
would be behind hoaxing something like
this cuz it seems kind of [__] up but
yeah it's like I I don't know I I could
kind of see maybe but like I said the
two uh candidates were the most likely
candidates at least according to most
internet theories about who this might
be um were uh Jack's mom or like I said
maybe his wife now the mom says that she
never knew any of his passwords which
okay like I don't think the mom lived
with that or anything like that so it's
not like I mean my mom doesn't know my
email passwords yeah so that would be
kind of weird if your mom knew your
passwords and you weren't 12 yeah you
know what I mean so I don't know um but
like I said maybe some people do write
them down somewhere so they can remember
I don't really write them down I just
try to remember them and that usually
doesn't go very well yeah but um but
yeah I kind of feel like if somebody is
Faking it maybe it's more likely the
wife because that's just you know she's
lives in your house she might know your
passwords and maybe I heard a theory
that it's like maybe um Jack was like
kind of a prankster and maybe he thought
it would be funny to have his wife [__]
with people after he was dead and like
email people as him well I was kind of
thinking that might have been a set
upbody um because here's the thing and I
don't know if you guys know this but
there are well obviously everybody knows
this but I mean emails you can schedule
send them you know what I mean so you
could write an email and theoretically
send it 6 months from now right and you
know I could be dead six months from now
like God forbid but um but if that
happens it would be like oh my God she's
writing to me from beyond the grave and
that'd be like super creepy right but
it's all all you do is schedule send but
there are services and like apps too
that will for shits and giggles like if
you want to do this to your family um
that will in the event of your death
will send emails like to whoever um to
yeah that will do that but here's the
thing you have to have written the
emails obviously before you died right
right now the emails that he sent
allegedly were referring to things that
had happened after he died either after
he died or [__] that only him and that
person supposedly knew about so I mean
it's possible like the whole thing about
cleaning the [__] attic um you know
it's possible that he could have just
written that email and then said you
know I'll send that later for whatever
reason but like I said I don't know if
he would knew he was going to die yeah a
guy in his 30s isn't thinking that way
that's what I mean so it's like I don't
really know this just like so weird
because it seems on the surface like
yeah it would be like a funny prank like
I said it's kind of [__] up but it is
kind of funny I admit what if it was
real I mean OB seen pure guys
[__] phenomena maybe this is real
maybe it's not necessarily him from the
spirit world maybe it's just something
else maybe it's a poltergeist doing it I
don't know weird possibly and like it's
just weird that it like specifically
referred to I don't know like I was
watching a thing about this and they
said they said yeah the whole thing
about the attic you know that could have
been um he could have sent that like
written it before he died now here's
here's the thing though what's that
these emails do we know these emails
were actually
sent yeah so there's proof of this
evidently this isn't just some story
somebody's telling not as far as I could
determine all right
okay it could be and it was more than
one person that they were sent to could
be the whole thing's a hoax that's
possible also in fact that's probably
what I'm leaning toward because I really
really don't think it goes to be sending
emails
yeah like I said I've heard about it
happening
before could be could be the whole
thing's a hoax some people were in on it
but a lot of the people in that family
weren't in on it and believed it just
something like that well and like I said
I was watching something earlier that
said that maybe the wife is doing it but
not to be cruel but because he said hey
if anything ever happens to me it would
be super
funny if you sent like all these emails
pretending to be me and she was like oh
I guess I should do do that like that
was like his final wish or whatever and
it's like but I don't know it's just
like a this is just like very very weird
to me and I know this is not the first
time this has happened because I know
that there's stories about people
getting like texts and emails and [__]
like that like from people that are dead
um but I don't know I've never really
seen any conclusive evidence because
there's so many ways that this could be
faked yeah there's a lot of weird [__]
about him referring to things that
apparently only he knew about or that
happened after he died but there's other
explanations for that and the fact that
you can send emails later the fact that
there are services that will do that for
you the fact that yeah he he sent the
email about the guy breaking the ankle
but I mean the fact that he even said in
the email it's like I kept warning you
about that like maybe the guy was doing
something all the time that was like
make it likely that he would and maybe
he was just like playing the odds like I
said but the fact that he wasn't
expecting to die is kind of throwing me
for a loop a little bit cuz if you were
knew you were dying and nobody knew yeah
it might be funny to like [__] with
people like that oh I'm going to send
all I'm going to write all these emails
to people and it's going to like freak
them the [__] out because I'm going to
send him after I'm dead and then they'll
think they're getting [__] messages
from Beyond the Grave I admit that would
be kind of funny I think it's his wife
although I don't think I would do that
because I don't I mean I would think
that was funny like but I'll be dead so
it's like I I kind of feel like that
would be a little bit cruel to do
because I don't know how other people
would react to it so I think that'd be
kind of shitty um so I probably wouldn't
do it even though I personally would
think it was kind of hilarious but the
thing but see and that's the thing too
it's like somebody if somebody I love
died and I got an email from them I'm
not I've never had that happen so I'm
not really sure how I would react to it
like I might think it was funny um but
then I might think it was kind of like
[__] up also I'm not really sure I've
never been in that situation so I don't
know how I'd feel about it so it's like
I just I would just kind of air on the
side of like not doing that because I
don't because some people might like
take it really the wrong way and not
think it was funny because I have like a
really morbid sense of humor and I know
that other people don't so I don't know
I I I don't know if the wife is doing
this or the mom is doing it or if he set
it up somehow before maybe he knew he
was going to die and like he didn't tell
anybody um or something and he set it up
because he thought it would be funny um
I'm not really sure like I said I I
think it's very unlikely that he's
emailing people from Beyond the Grave um
because I just don't think that happens
so there has to be some other
explanation so it's got to be one of
those things it's either somebody else
is doing it or he set it up like before
he died somehow but I don't know I how
would you guys feel if like somebody you
love died and then like six months later
you got an email ostensibly from them
that seemed like it was from them and
they were talking about [__] that had
happened in the 6 months subsequently
I'm not really sure how I would feel
about that you know how would you feel
about that
Tom I'm trying to like worry about it
well no I'm well I'm trying to put
myself in the shoes of somebody cuz I've
never been in this
situation um suspect fraud first yeah so
would I I'd be like who the [__] and
then I'd be mad because I'm like who the
[__] is like toying with my emotions
like that like thinking this person's
contacting me from Beyond the Grave or
some [__] like that that's like not cool
so I'd probably be mad I'd start asking
it questions and if it couldn't or
didn't answer them correctly then right
I'd blow it off yeah I probably would
too yeah blo dude said I would think
it's a glitch yeah that could be too
like it could have been emails that he
wrote before and they for whatever
reason like didn't get mailed I don't
really know uh bled dude also says happy
belated birthday Jen thank you very much
I had a really fun one had a little
two-day mini vacation so that was kind
of nice got on all the rides and stuff
we'll talk about it on the Sidetrack
show tomorrow night we can talk about
all the [__] that I did and we can tell
you can talk about [__] you did while I
was away all the trouble you got into I
didn't really do much you didn't get
into trouble no I heard about it went to
back bike night that's he went to bike
night and sent me video yeah hang out
with
Lloyd hang out with Lloyd the white girl
Whisperer the white girl Whisperer yeah
that's what I called him white we'll
talk about that
tomorrow dude had a whole stable of
white
girls just like the stable of stall
yeah he's my new buddy
man Tom also wants to know how how to
have a stable of white
women he's like teach me your ways no we
knew the same ways we already knew the
same ways we were already Bros [__]
we were already Bros yeah we already had
already had the same ways [__] this [__]
was funny I'll introduce them to you
yeah well that apparently well you said
they own a restaurant down there yeah
they got a Jamaican restaurant his his
parents are from Jamaica is it the
restaurant that I'm thinking of it might
be ask him I think there's only one
Jamaican restaurant he hit me up today F
says says where you at I said my home he
says I'm over in Orlando come on down
here I says I got a show I got to do
he's like
damn okay oh well yeah he's got a
gsxr1000 drag bike big old long extended
well I mean we got a show tomorrow too
but right yeah I don't know I I don't
know if we need to do streamate tomorrow
I showed him some stuff of me and you
and [__] yeah he's like damn I can't
believe she's 51 and she she's fine and
I said yeah I'm I'll introduce you to
you and she was like all right you know
just you know oh is he gonna try to like
get me into his into his stable
affiliate no no he's not like that if he
did he he'd have like two or three to
trade tray oh you going to trade me in
for no no no
no you said maybe he'd have if he did
some [__] like that he'd have some [__]
for trade yeah Tom's do you hear that
Tom's gonna trade me for like two other
random way
yeah y'all are [__] I'm have I'm gon
have to show I'm gonna have to show
Lloyd at least it's I'm gonna show
Lloyd I was impressed with Lloyd Lloyd's
about Lloyd's about 5 foot n he's 37 5
foot n [__] probably weighs
about 180 lbs maybe 10% body fat and
never touched a weight in his life he's
[__] just Rock Solid just all
genetics all genetics and uh [__] we
were just we were just talking hanging
out during Bike Night Zach says Tom the
ever thoughtful wife pimper it's [__]
hilarious y'all are [__]
uncontrollable y'all un [__]
controllable I'm just joking around
we're we're just we're just riing off
what you're talking
about all right [__] where it is oh my
that's me and Lloyd yeah there you go
there me and Lloyd B yeah he sent me
that yeah I was at Epcot and he sent me
that
on yeah lloy looks young too man [__]
he's he's uh
37 so considerably young yeah but his
parents own the damn Jamaican restaurant
down there in downtown Sanford I've
never eaten at that so I'm gonna but it
does look good yeah I'm going to check
that out I'm [__] asking which
exactly one it is yeah I think there
might only be one Jamaican restaurant in
there if it's the one I'm thinking of
I haven't seen any other ones down there
because downtown sford is pretty small
dbg Dragon says Tom brags about all his
friends bricked up for Jenny LOL yeah
yeah yeah yeah he said that to me
yesterday he was like yeah I always brag
about I know I know I brag about you I
know you do about how you're going to
trade me for two other white women she's
fuing he's like wait well well let me
see what you got first before what do
you got for it's [__] players man
players
it's
F it's like oh well okay that's tempting
that's tempting I'm not gonna y'all are
bad I know we're terrible yeah well hey
like I said you say the [__] so I'm
playing I'm just I'm just ripping I'm
just playing around you know trying to
get serious I'm just playing around too
I just I'm just I'm just feeling out
making sure I'm just like oh [__] am I
going to get traded off to I'm G to get
traded off [__] no it's biker world but
it's not that bad we're just playing
we're just playing yeah just I'm not get
traded that's good that's good um all
right so what what how long have we been
okay so yeah I was probably smart not to
do four cases it was okay so we only
have one left um and this one I kind of
feel like this is maybe the most famous
one I'm not really sure I always
perceived this was the most famous one
this was like the first one I heard
about um but this
case is known as uh
11bx 1371 um probably I don't know if
it's better known as like the plague
doctor video um if you kind of search
for creepy internet Mysteries it's
usually one of the first things that
come up right after like cicada 3301 and
even if you go to the cicada 3301 like
Wikipedia page it'll link to this page
like on the bottom because it's kind of
similar so this was a
video that was that kind of came to
light back around
and if You' seen it it's about 2 minutes
well actually it's exactly 2 minutes
long and it's a dude in a plague doctor
get up like kind of wandering around
this
abandoned building kind of situation
it's in black and white and there's this
weird um like noise in the background
and then there's like all these kind of
weird like what seems to be like encoded
messages and stuff and it's pretty
creepy I mean it has been compared to
that creepy ass video from The Ring
which it's not quite that creepy but
it's pretty creepy um you know so so and
there's all these kind of like [__] on
the screen that like I said they turned
out to be coded [__] later
on so um there's no uh credits on this
no saying like who made it or anything
like that now this first came to light
in around October of
2015 and when people started noticing it
and people started kind of looking into
the history of the backstory um it was
actually noted because when it kind of
came to light mostly was when this dude
um he was a Swedish guy and there was a
like a blog a website called Gadget
zz.com and he actually posted the video
on the blog and said we got this in the
mail and I'm not really sure where it
came from like there's no address or
anything like that and I he's like it
seems like to have encoded messages in
it but I can't figure them out so he
posted it like on the public forum to
like see if other people could help him
out so after he did that um people
looked back and they said oh well this
was actually uploaded to YouTube in I
believe April or May of 2015 like
earlier um and this was actually the
title I don't think it was the title of
it but it was kind of like just right in
the description box it was like this
long um binary code and if you um
decrypted the binary code it's spelled
uh Muerte which is obviously the Spanish
word for death which it seems a little
threatening so there's that now the
person that posted the video was a user
named AE
tbx and um so they basically they said
they didn't make the video um their
story was that um that it had been like
that he someone had sent it to him you
know what I mean and then he thought it
was weird so he posted it so when it was
sent to um the guy at Gadget ZZ whose
name was um Johnny C cicler cigler is I
think you how you pronounce his last
name he basically
said um that this was sent it was the
the envelope was postmarked from Warsaw
Poland and was addressed to Johnny K
which is kind of what his uh you know
name was and sent care of the websites
like PO Box no return address no nothing
and then he's like inside this package
and there's pictures of the package if
you want to look it up um there was a
DVD in there and they're like written on
the DVD was this kind of like um alpha
numeric string um in two lines uh which
he at first thought was a product key
key he said the first thing that he
thought was this was somebody had sent
me some software for me to review cuz
that was what they did at this website
um but so he took it to a computer and
like played it but instead this video
turned up and he wasn't really sure what
it was and then like I said he started
noticing there was like all these
[__] weird codes and letters and [__]
like that like hidden in there so he
decided to put it online and see if you
know people could like kind of
crowdsource like what it was out and
this is the post that he originally made
he said we received a letter from Poland
containing a really weird CD actually a
DVD uh written on the disc is what looks
like a product key however upon
examining the contents of the CD it's
quite clear that this is a puzzle of
some sort the CD contains a video of
This creepy looking dude in what appears
to be an abandoned building doing stuff
there are tons of yeah there are tons of
it's a weird video if you've ever seen
it is very creep
there are tons of clues in his actions
for one he seems to be blinking in Morse
code or something similar possibly
binary with a light in his hand there
are also symbols popping in and out
around him there might also be clues in
his body language albeit more subtle in
the DVD menu there is also a clue which
I almost missed clearly a lot of effort
was put into making this and I'm
personally very curious as what it
actually is I haven't put all that much
time into trying to decode it I tried
Googling the letters on the CD and in
the video to no avail I also checked the
dis for hidden files but there's just
the video also there didn't seem to be
any clues on the envelope itself just
our address and a Polish stamp and while
there are a few similar puzzles like
this I couldn't find anything about this
one so I'm reaching out to you to try
and help decode this so that's what he
did he posted on the blog with that
message and try to get people to like
help him
out now they found out um like I said
that somebody had posted it earlier to
YouTube at BX like back in Spring of 200
uh 15 and that video at that time I
don't know about now was the only video
that was on that channel um and the
binary code like I said spelled
Muerte um and appar apparently it had
been up there for several months and all
suddenly like after the um Gadget ZZ
post went kind of viral um everybody
went back and started looking at the old
one again and aetbx was like why is
everybody suddenly watching this video
that I posted like 5 months ago so it
like this whole thing happened so at
that point like the Washington Post
contacted uh the Youtube user that had
supposedly first posted it um he
wouldn't tell them his real name he said
that his name was Daniel and that he was
from Spain and he said um I didn't make
this video but this was also sent to me
in the mail um he said that some girl
had emailed him like he didn't know this
girl and she said that she had found it
on a park bench and decided to mail it
to him I don't this story doesn't really
sound all that plausible because one you
find some random DVD on a park bench
that has a weird video like this on it
it's like I'm just going to mail it to
this random person because she said he
said he didn't know this girl so I don't
really know if I believe this story or
not but yeah um and then as they kind of
investigated further they found that
there was actually an earlier posting um
prior to YouTube that somebody had
actually posted it on the Paranormal
board on forchan like slightly earlier
to that but they also contacted the
person that had posted it there they
don't know if it's the same person that
posted it on YouTube and um that person
whether it's the same person or not also
claimed that they had not made the video
and they did not know where it came from
so at this point the video has been kind
of like posted all over it's on Reddit
it's on Twitter it's on Tumblr um and
even like kind of larger like mainstream
media was trying to take notice of it
and trying to figure out like where it
came from and what it meant now so what
they did find out like uh a lot of
people were able to decode some [__] and
what they decoded from this video was
like pretty [__] weird now as I said
the inscription on the
dis uh was 11b dx- 1371 which is usually
what the video is called nowadays um and
that was in base 64 which is um you know
binary to text en coding um so that
eventually came to be what the video was
called somebody else had the bright idea
to make a spectrogram of the sound
because it has a very distinctive like
very kind of a grading like sound in the
background so they made a spectrogram of
that and inside the audio uh there were
text and images hidden in there
um the text in the audio that was kind
hidden in the audio said you are already
dead um the images that were hidden in
the audio were all pictures of women
being mutilated and tortured and uh you
know dead women no hold on hold on now
what these these pictures were from what
serial killers or they were dra well
that's what they thought at first
they're photos okay you know there were
photos they were encoded inside the
audio of the video cuz you can do that
okay you know what I mean um so at first
when that was first discovered they're
like holy [__] this is a serial killer
but then they found out that of the
pictures that were in there um one of
them was from a horror movie called The
Bunny Game okay one of them was from a
German horror movie called
slasher and one of the photos was
actually a legit photo of a murder
victim but it was a ver um it was one of
the victims of the Boston Strangler okay
so it was a um a picture that you could
so whoever whoever's doing this they
[__] yeah they weren't like killing
but but like I said at first when nobody
recognized because those are kind of
slightly obscure horror movies so you
wouldn't necessarily like recognize them
right away um so it's somebody that kind
of wanted maybe to think people to think
that I don't really know um now also
they did um there was a spectrogram the
sound spectrogram they on the DVD
menu um that came up with a picture of a
skull and then there were more coded
messages in there um and they
also the thing that came up in the
description I think like in the YouTube
video when it was posted um said
something and it's in Spanish I'm not
going to like uh attempt to pronounce it
but the English translation was you have
one less year that was the translation
of that also um near the end of the
video there was like a um little kind of
triangle and square kind of symbol
message thing and that was found to say
something in Latin which translated to
to attack or Target men so somebody that
like knew what they were doing like did
this you know what I mean they also
found that in the 2-minute video there
were like little single frame
inserts these inserts had Morse code and
other texts in there that were in sort
of um ciphers but not real complicated
ciphers you know what I mean uh the
morse code they actually translated to
red lips like tenth that was one thing
that said which we'll talk about what
that might mean later on um they also
found a sequence of uh 20 pairs of two
digit characters and this was discovered
to be the latitude and longitude of the
White House in Washington DC okay um and
they also determined that the morse code
that said red lips Lake 10th if you um
they thought maybe that that was an
anagram for kill the
president because you know I think
there's one like one letter off but yeah
that's an anagram for kill the president
now because of that um and because there
were some other uh like weird codes in
there that people decoded to say uh
strike an arrow through the heart of the
eagle uh there was one in there that
said that there was also a code in there
that said a new order will rise 13 and
50 will
burn um so people thought maybe they
were talking about the American flag CU
like I said it used to have you know 13
stars and then 50 stars so they like
talking about that um so because of all
that because of the whole kill the
president and the white house uh
coordinates and all that kind of stuff
so at the time when you know uh you know
the the authorities got wind of it they
sort of started treating it as they
would as a terrorist threat like a you
know for an assassination attempt um
again and at the time it was Barack
Obama so they were thinking that maybe
someone was going to try to assassinate
the president like this person was doing
that so um so yeah some people also
thought that because the guy in the
video was wearing like a plague doctor
outfit that it was going to be a
specifically like biot
terrorism kind of attack right because
one of the messages it was like a plane
text message in there that said the
eagle I think it was like an equal sign
infected will spread his disease where
the antivirus will protect the world
body uh and also because the video had
the number 1371 in it um you know that
may might have been a reference to the
Black Death so they were kind of
thinking maybe this is you know kind of
some kind of like encoded threat you
know like a biot terrorism threat so
they did actually kind of like look into
that because you know that does seem
like a legitimate even though it's
hidden but you know people figured it
out so they you know
not too long I think it was less than a
month after um you know the the Swedish
guy G Gadget easy had like posted the
video and like the information that he
had about it um most of the codes and
stuff like that in there had been
deciphered um there were a couple left
in there that no one could figure out I
don't know if anyone's figured them out
at this point I don't think
so um and there are other things in
there that seem to cuz he's making like
weird hand gestures and [__] like that
too so um it could be like some people
thought that the uh the kind of like
other codes and like hand gers he was he
was making was maybe referring to um the
Enigma machine you know what I mean from
uh from the war that where they figured
out the codes and everything so
it so it could have been that um so I
don't know but nobody's like really
figured those out but the ones they did
figure out were alarming enough that uh
you know that that people were kind of
starting to take notice um one of the
other uh messages that I think they
figured out from it was said something
like complacent are the weak stand and
fight with us take down the black beast
kill his disease or fall with the rest
that was one of the messages as well so
you know again like kind of
threatening um now for a time because
here's the thing in
args um were quite common I was G to say
that Viral marketing [__] was quite
common so at this point one of the I
think one of the overwhelming like one
of the big theories at the time was that
oh um they were adapting what 2015 what
was that Dan Brown novel that they were
adapting at that time because he writes
all those kind of
conspiratorial um was it not D Vinci
Code or something like yeah but
everybody else does um but yeah he
writes kind of all those like d Vinci
Code type stuff so um so they thought
maybe because there was a movie of one
of his novels coming out that maybe it
was viral marketing for that but they're
like well but nobody really attempted to
I don't know it would be kind of like a
roundabout way of doing it and and you
would think that if it was like a big
Hollywood studio doing viral marketing
which they do um you'd want to kind of
keep away from [__] like kill the
president and stuff you know what I mean
that that might be a little like
problematic um so I you know so people
are leaning more toward corporate right
that this is probably not uh a corporate
thing like very very unlikely yeah now
around this time like I said it only
took a few months like before people
started figuring some [__] out and then
this name Parker Wright starts getting
sort of thrown around now he had also
uploaded a version of this
video but he denied that he had made it
and then like later on deleted his
profile But as time went on he actually
would come forward later and said that
he had been the person that made it I
don't know if this is the case but he
came forward and said that he had made
it he said um he came on Twitter at like
a like a month or two like after the
video had kind of gone viral and he said
um to whoever it was that was trying to
decode the stuff he's like you are no
closer to understanding the message
that's what he said um but he said that
I wanted to put this thing out and I
wanted everybody to work together to
break the codes um because no one person
could figure out the whole thing now he
said that he did this as an art project
and he said that he had always meant to
make more videos but he had just so far
only made that one he has s made two
more apparently if it was really him um
most people think it probably was him or
he had something to do with it because
he was able to produce the plague doctor
mask which is kind of specific it's not
just like a random one that you could
buy it was one that he made himself and
it was made of leather and had like
these weird eyes that kind of look like
coins and stuff and he was able to
produce that and he made another video
like on his channel that had that in it
so it probably is him but it probably
yeah so it probably is him but nobody is
entirely sure like why he made it though
like he said that he just made it as an
art project but what year was this again
2015 was when it first came kind late
for this kind of [__] like I said it
seems very ARG but it's like if you're
going to do an ARG normally what they
would do is that yeah you'd put out a
video like that and kind of wait for it
to go viral and then you'd like keep on
with it like you keep putting [__] out
and the fact that he just put that one
two-minute video out and then he didn't
put out another one for like
years later I don't know it just seems
really weird and I'm not really sure
like what he was trying to get across
with
it um I mean he was from California I
guess he was a film student and he said
that when he made the video he had been
living in Poland cuz that's where the
video was made people were able to
determine from looking at the building
and stuff like that that that's where it
was and actually I think they even like
narrowed it down to like where the ACT
what actual building it was cuz people
recognized it from that part of the
world
um but he said they interviewed him
later so if this is the guy that
actually made the [__] he said I didn't
enter into my project without first
finding out where my rights stand as an
American citizen because they were
asking him it's like were were you
worried at all about making kind of
veiled threats against a sitting
president like was that bothering you
and he said that he made it like knowing
what his rights were and that he would
be able to get away with it I guess um
he said art is very protected medium for
speech as it would appear uh the more
political that speech the more protected
it is that being said yes my work has
attracted that variety of attention as I
understand they are enter they are
entertained but not worried if they get
worried they'll let me know I think they
have more realistic focuses when they
aren't on their lunch break that's what
he said so he's kind of being like a
little bit snarky there um and he said
he said that the video had attracted
government attention um but he doesn't
seem that worried about it and he says
he's not up to any anything quote
unquote illegal or Shady so he's not
really worried about
it um even though it does seem like he
threatened the president so you know
what I mean but but I don't know uh he
also said I see my work as waves on the
ocean some people look for shells in it
some surf others
dive which you know whatever um so yeah
because this video took off in
2015 he did make two more uh he made one
called uh 11b sl3 SL uh not SL Dash uh
1369 that was at the end of 2015 so
several months after that I gone viral
uh and then he made another one called
11b uh-
45-1 78 I think it is um but that one he
didn't put up until 2019 they're kind of
similar but there's another person in
them um and it's a woman who has like
this weird mask thing over her face and
it seems as there's no dialogue or
anything like that but it seems as
though she's like a captive of the
plague doctor I guess that's what he's
trying to get across um but there's
other kind of like coded [__] in there
but the thing about it is that once he
came out and claimed responsibility and
like I said I'm not sure if he's the guy
that did it or if he's just like riding
on the coattails but once everybody
thought that he was the dude that did it
it seems like no one was really
interested in figuring out the cyphers
anymore they're like right well because
and that's what we were talking about
with the most mysterious song on the
internet earlier it's like in a way I
would like for them to find out who that
is yeah and you know so the person can
get recognition or whatever if they're
still around which they may not be but
then in another way it's like it's not
as fun like if you know who it is
because it's then it's just mundane when
it's a mystery it's a mystery and
there's all these possibilities when you
narrow it down to this one oh it was
this one thing it's like it's not really
fun anymore and like nobody really wants
to play because why would you all the
possibilities are gone because it's been
winnowed down to one
possibility I would say that yeah that
applies to this yeah that's people lost
interest when they had a good lead on
who it was and this this is 2015 to 19
that's very late for this kind of stunt
yeah you know what I mean this is like
the ARG [__] [__] really this was
something from the late
90s yeah
so we know this [__] Motif we know
that thing you know [__] making
spooky videos with codes that went out
of style yeah the the but the thing is
is with the [__] most mysterious song
on the interet that's still viable we
just want to know who that is yeah and
if we know who that is then it'd be
solved I think yeah and then people were
like oh okay yeah then that's cool and
that that song wouldn't be
forgotten yeah probably not because then
there'd be a story behind it there' be a
story yeah I kind of the thing about ARG
I love argies I'm not saying that but
it's just kind of like there's so many
um you know I think back in maybe 2015
or earlier like it was maybe easier to
get a foothold if you posted something
like this I mean obviously somebody
would see it it would go viral somewhere
and like everybody it would explode in
popularity but because of that then
everybody started trying to do it and
now it's like a lot harder to get
noticed because so many people are
trying to do it so it's like you know so
it's almost like it's almost like become
a Trope at this point like in the ARG
thing it's like oh somebody sent some
mysterious person sent me this yeah you
know old this old media and I'm just I
didn't make it I'm just like uploading
it and showing it to you and you have to
help me figure out what it is that's a
very common like ARG Trope which I get
because it works and that's you know
listen to what Zach says read what Zach
says he said well if that's not the most
pretentious film student [__] I've
ever heard I agree I I also agree it
kind of is um and and look I you know
I'm an artist myself I'm very into that
kind of stuff but I I have like a lot
more grounded
um understanding of that [__] I guess so
and there is a lot of [__] involved
because especially in the art world
where you know you want you want to be
the next big thing you want to be the
person that you know dumb rich people
are paying like millions of dollars for
you know my [__] in a can or whatever
like like that Italian artist yeah dud
that [__] came in the damn box
underneath his bed try to sell it right
right right so so if you can come up
with a good story for why somebody
should pay millions of dollars for that
then in a way I almost kind of admire
that but it's [__] I think that most
of the artists know it's [__] too
well most you just got to talk you got
to talk a good game that's all most of
that [__] high art stuff ask David
Bowie he'll tell you most of that he's
dead of course uh most of that high art
maybe he'll email us was about was about
money laundering really that yeah
probably yeah yeah
so I and and like I said I'm not one of
those crabby ass people that's like oh
like modern art it's all because I've
seen a lot of Modern Art that I
like but I'm talking more about [__]
like like I said that Italian art I
can't remember what his name is but I
remember hearing about him in college
that just kind of like you know pooped
in a can you know and I think the thing
was called like whatever the Italian
equivalent of artist [__] is and I'm
like look hey if you can [__] in a can
and get some dumb [__] to pay
millions of dollars for it fair play to
you fair play to you it was money
laundering
though or who was that who was the guy
that well now I'm not going to [__] on
this too much because I think this is
kind of cool but um who is the guy that
does the what's his [__] name that
does like the cutup Sharks and all that
what's his [__] name I don't know God
damn it's right on the [__] sharks
what you talking about yeah it's like
this big huge [__] tank and it's just
like a shark but it's like cut up I
haven't seen that yeah it's actually
kind of cool looking and he was kind of
like the IT thing for a while um but he
I I mean I'm not going to [__] on that
too hard like I said cuz I thought that
kind that [__] was kind of cool but I'm
not going to pay millions of dollars for
it even if I had it but but I thought it
was kind of cool to look at you know I'd
go look at it in a museum and be like Oh
neat I don't know but um but yeah the
whole thing about just making a nest of
hair or whatever and then like getting
people to pay millions of dollars for
that like I said if you can come up with
a good [__] pretentious ass story
about why you did that then the British
guy yeah what
God damn it it's like right on the tip
of my tongue I'm not that drunk I don't
know why I can't remember it I don't
know why I can't think I'll probably
think of it like in the middle of the
night um uh Lynwood s said uh where is
is that damn Jenny 1,000 other women
would not compare a that's very nice of
you to say that's very nice of you to
say because I was talking about the I
was talking about all his other
girlfriend yeah it's all [__] we're
all just Mak stuff up it's going to be
all right Tom just makes stuff up I
wasn't making it up but you know it's
all fun Damian HST thank you very much
thank you I knew someone would come up
with it it's like yeah the dude's
[__] famous I just couldn't think of
his name yeah thank you very much
Isabella because otherwise that was GNA
drive me crazy like all night long I
don't about you but I'm hungry yeah yeah
okay yeah I kind of is that all three
cases I think so yeah I think we
finished everything up so so like I said
this the plague doctor thing maybe is
solved we think it's just this P I don't
think that's that dude's real name
that's just the name that he uses but he
said he made it he had the mask
um and he made other videos like in that
same style so I'm imagining it's him
like I said I'm not really sure what his
motiv died down and there wasn't yeah
like it's not a mystery anymore like I
said people like Mysteries if you solve
the mystery then it's not fun anymore
it's not fun anymore well people
probably weren't trying that hard so he
came
out Jeffy art said was it at Art uh oh
yeah art basil or Bassel or whatever
they call that's isn't that down in
Miami or whatever or no that's in
Switzerland I can't remember uh that a
guy taped a banana to a wall and sold it
for
$120,000 see like I said in a way yeah
that's that's like terrible but it's
also I admire the grift I admire the
grift telling y'all cuz [__] if I could
tape a banana to a wall and like get
$120,000 I would absolutely do it
they're not actually buy I'll even come
up with a [__] story about they're
not actually buying that all right it's
[__] money laundering the
[__] yeah they [__] dirty money and
buy that the [__] artist gets a
commission then he kicks back all the
rest of it to clean the [__] money
that's all it is Ben said I admire that
Danish artist who sold the invisible
sculpture to a gallery oh my God that's
[__] brilliant why didn't I think of
that God damn it God damn it I wish I
thought of that yeah yeah it is in Miami
okay so I wasn't I wasn't wrong I wasn't
wrong well because I did a couple years
ago I did a um like some social media uh
graphic design for a for somebody that
was um like a perfume company that was
going to be there and they had like
these artist like really cool like
artistic perfume bottles and I remember
doing the ads for that and that's in
Miami so yeah uh the satellite events
are way cooler in my opinion yeah
invisible sculpture [__] man why don't I
think of the good [__] I could have been
$120,000 richer right now if I had just
thought of that can I still do invisible
painting or has somebody thought of that
already I mean I know they've already
thought of like hey it's a white canvas
you know what I mean I know they've
already done that I'm I'm too late I'm
I'm too late jumping on that boat but
yeah I don't know invisible painting
though that's some that's some Next
Level
[__] yeah DVD Dr oh this is pretty funny
DVD Dragon said uh yeah Florida massage
parlors have some Modern Art on the
walls and ceilings if you bringing a u
light hotel rooms too they have some
really nice uh some Jackson Pollock
style like action going on in there one
of these days I think we've mentioned
this on the show before but uh across
the street from the Chinese buffet we go
to there's a massage parlor we're not
sure if it's one of the fun massage
parlor like the happy ending massage
parlor but it's like we never see
anybody parked there so we're always
kind of like mystified it's like and it
always seems open but there doesn't ever
we never see anybody going in or out we
never see any cars and I'm just like
Tom's like we should go in there one
day that massage parlor well because DVD
Dragon said Florida massage parlers have
some Modern Art on the walls and
ceilings if you bring in a UV light me J
want to go to there we could get a
[__] [__] happy ending man want to
videotape the
[__] I'm like get a good we'll we'll
sell it on we'll sell it on our many
sell that [__]
many that's what we'll do but yeah all
right so we should probably wrap this
I'll make something to eat I'm hungry
yeah you hungry yeah I'm sorry I got
everything that makes make make pizza I
got a pizza dough oh yeah we should cuz
I was going to say when did we eat I was
like oh my God I ate a ate once we ate I
ate a frittata and that was like yeah oh
that was a long time ago that was like
breakfast time you had a you had a four
egg fata so did I that's right so we're
we're on calor restriction long time ago
yeah all right so we are going to wrap
it up yeah uh so thank you everybody for
dropping by hope you guys enjoyed the
show remember it's Thursday night
tonight so tomorrow night we'll be here
for the Sidetrack show which is always
fun so we're going to get even drunker
probably wait a minut none on a Friday
yeah tomorrow we'll do a small one we
might go out that night yeah we'll find
out we'll see what's going on we'll see
what's going going we'll see what's
going we we'll do at least we'll we'll
do one tomorrow may not be one where
we're going to get rior and drun though
yeah we'll see because we might have to
go out I want to go to mannequins yeah
we haven't been to man haven't been on
mannequins in a long time yeah maybe
we'll go to mannequins tomorrow night
see if I get paid tonight I was going to
say as long as you're paying if I get
paid tonight we'll because I don't got
no money yeah but uh but yeah so but
we'll definitely do a Sidetrack tomor
talk about Disney we'll talk about uh
the white woman
Whisperer we'll talk about we'll talk
about all I'm going to call Lloyd to
mannequins tomorrow if we go okay yeah
yeah you'll meet Lloyd okay well yeah
like take some videos of them all right
said bring one of your white girls or
one of your black girls he brought a
black girl with him last time tell him
to bring the whole hair he's got like
five white ones in I'm not joining it
though I'm just tell he's married to a
white woman I think they might be
separated I'm not
sure he showed me the pictures I was
like okay yeah okay we were at bike
night and he was [__] working his
magic I saw this [__] [__] work
firsthand I you're the white girl
whisper he's like yeah he's the only
Alpha [__] them me and him the
only Alpha [__] around there
all the [__] little fat boys and [__]
you know there's a lot of Frat Boys down
there not Frat Boys Fat Boys well Frat
Boys and fat Bo yeah yeah they're all
fat all college boys yeah we went to the
[__] you know across the street from
the uh arcade place what's it called
Throwbacks they got a couple of those
little bars over there we went there
that's a little College bar oh okay and
they had all these little College type
people there and we walked in there man
we were looking all it was all white
people and [__] uh All Them White
Boys were [__] up
looking did they have cargo shorts and
Crocs on yeah and just [__] fat and
[__] like you know out of shape [__]
dumpy and every female eyeball fell on
me on me and Lloyd Fu the whole only
good looking people yeah but then
his his black chick showed up he he uh
[__] went to high school with her and
then she dominated the whole [__]
crowd I should have got that [__] on
video I pulled the [__] camera out
cuz she was riding on his lap like that
you know I say oh I got to get this I'm
going to put this on [__] only vids
or [__] only video and he's like yeah
yeah do it but then I was like N I was
like no I going to do it I'll get in
trouble well no cuz well yeah one you'll
get in trouble and two you need to
release for that kind of [__] you need
to release that sh it's too much trouble
yeah you can't like just put random
people on there but the food there was
pretty good man we had those $15
hamburgers they were pretty good on J
bread yeah I don't think I've ever eaten
there yeah we'll go there I don't think
I've ever been in there we'll go there
downtown Sanford all right so maybe yeah
downtown Zord is pretty F yeah I had
that damn [__] barbecue burger it was
on a toasted chabata bread big ass
[__] hamburger with barbecue sauce
and [__] three onion rings on top of
it with some pickles and [__] that [__]
was good pickles and [__] pickles and
[__] I like that I like the onion ring
yeah all right well yeah so maybe we'll
go to downtown s we haven't been in a
while right hopefully you won't get in
any fights hopefully I won't get in any
fights no no it should be okay I'll try
not to I'll [__] tell I'll tell Tom
I'm coming
say clear clear the area okay I'm not on
Trend no right but still I mean well but
the thing about it is that mean if
somebody grabs your ass I'm going fight
well that well yeah I probably how it so
I I wouldn't blame you when I ran
through two of them that cuz I said yeah
I'll probably hit them also yeah so I
ran through two of them that night I'm
lucky that I didn't go to jail but they
they couldn't [__] call the cops
because they assaulted her so yeah so
that's what I mean they were scared to
call the cop well good they should be
yeah [__] [__] up man don't [__]
touch me
yeah you'll be you'll be sorry went
[__] crazy yeah you did I can't help
it A all right let's go you're so
protective let's go all right so I
didn't think about it just I know yeah
all right so we're gonna go get
something to eat yeah so you guys have a
good rest of your evening we'll see you
guys again tomorrow night come have a
drink with us and have our yeah
sidetracks chat which is always super
fun uh so good night you guys bye